commission
enforcement
so
as chair of housing dna i find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of the velvet
19 pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12
personal to executive order 202004
this public body is authorized to meet
electronic
this is not a public this is a meeting
on the performance audit of the liquor
commission it was scheduled in the house
calendar
and an executive session may be held on
any bill referred to the committee
there's no physical location for members
of the public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
so
[Applause]
[Music]
yes the fire is out everyone that feels
safe you may breathe freely
all members of the committee's both
committees and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform for by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs like.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
all votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
let's start competing by taking rule
paul attendant
when each member states their present
please also state where there's anyone
in the room with you during the meeting
which is required under the right to
know law representative huntsman's your
clerk
uh unfortunately my clerk is not going
to be able to attend this meeting today
he just discovered it and in that case
i'll have my clerk start by taking this
bdna attendance and then we'll you can
decide who takes the role i gotta get
printed out on my list okay um
no
representative font no i am home and my
wife is in the house
representing the goalie
home and my wife is in the other room
is present in her office at home alone
representative
[Music]
representative judy
representative
[Music]
i'm a nashua mobile there may be people
in and out
representative
representative mcguire
presence in the committee representative
o'brien
representative
[Music]
i'm
and i'm alone
representative
[Music]
i'm sorry i couldn't hear did you call
shoot
yes
representative schuett is at her home in
pembroke alone
pierson
representative uh schultz
good morning i'm at my residence in
concord and my husband taylor will be
heading out of the room
park is in the room
to
okay representative osborn
[Music]
representative abramson
okay
uh
representative ham
okay
representative palmer
you're in a loan
right representative greeson
president alone
representative johnson
here in the lb
representative terry
i am alone i am here until 10 40 a.m and
may be back later depending on how long
the hearing goes
uh representative bartlett
here in my home
alone
representative abel
is not able to attend representative
herbert
uh representative van halen
hey
representative fargo i'm here in my home
alone
and representative weston
and representative bilo
home alone
and
representative burroughs
uh here alone in my office
and representative mcgallery
you clear sorry
i'm here my wife is in the house with me
okay and i am representative hunt and i
am all alone in my office
so
it's all yours not a chair
thank you very much i'm going to call
on mr stephen smith head of the audit
division
mr smith you can unmute yourself and
speak
sorry about that
for the record i'm steve smith i'm the
director of audits for the lba
and
we've been asked to present the our
performance audit of the liquor
commission
division of enforcement licensing
uh i will advise both committees that we
did present this audit report to the
fiscal committee at its march excuse me
february 19th meeting
and um
joining me this morning is steve grady
he's our senior audit manager for us
and he oversaw was the in charge on this
on this audit
and so i've asked him to present
um the report
much like we did for the fiscal
committee so steve
i saw you earlier so feel free to
i will director thank you and uh thank
you madam chair for uh having us
for the record i am steve grady the
in-charge auditor for the division of
enforcement and licensing performance
audit
the audit was designed to determine how
efficiently and effectively the division
operated during state fiscal years 2018
and 2019.
due to the report's length i will be
summarizing observations and chapters
our executive summary captures main
themes and the most significant concerns
it is there that we conclude the
commission lacked adequate management
controls to ensure the division achieved
expected outcomes
our recommendation summary follows
our recommendations typically focus on
commission and division management
improving controls to help achieve
expected outcomes
increasing commission oversight of
division performance and complying with
laws and rules
of the 47 recommendations management
concurred with 44 and concurred in part
with three
11 contains elements that may require
legislative action
chapter 1 addresses systemic management
control deficiencies management control
is a process that if well designed
properly implemented monitored and
refined can help management efficiently
and effectively comply with laws and
rules achieve objectives and protect
resources
however at times controls were absent
ineffectively designed inconsistently
implemented unmonitored and unrefined
some long-standing unresolved
deficiencies resulted in abuse and waste
some controls and corresponding actions
were unauditable because they were
poorly documented and relevant records
were unreliable
we were compelled to qualify our use of
and our conclusions resting on division
records the operating environment and
organizational culture were not
conducive to the development
implementation monitoring and refinement
of effective controls there was no
apparent design to division management
controls
neither the commission nor the division
strategically planned or managed
internal operations
there were no complementary strategies
or plans designed to achieve outcomes
supporting statewide strategies such as
those related to public health and
highway safety
management lacked a coordinated
systematic approach to risk management
leading to qualitative intuition based
practices
without a formal objective risk
assessment there was no way to determine
what risks division practices were
designed to mitigate
without any cost benefit or similar
analyses there was no way to determine
whether practices efficiently mitigated
risks
external evaluations such as audits can
help identify and manage risks
however
unresolved untimely resolved and
temporarily resolved defects contributed
to ongoing and in some cases worsening
management control deficiencies
we evaluated 21 relevant observations
from seven prior audits and found one
was fully resolved
we repeated 20 prior observations in
this report
some topics were previously addressed as
many as seven times and some were
initially identified as far back as 1989
here we suggest the legislature consider
increasing its oversight of commission
efforts to address the conditions
leading to audit observations
compliance with laws and rules was a
basic expectation
but management lacked controls to ensure
the statutory framework was optimized
statutes were complex and commission
rules amplified statutory complexity
to fill in gaps within the statutory and
regulatory framework the division
undertook broad ad-hoc rulemaking some
knowingly some unknowingly
ad hoc rulemaking is an extra legal
practice of enforcing requirements on
the public without underpinning statute
or properly adopted rule
ad hoc rules affected each division
function
controls to ensure division compliance
with laws and rules were absent and
controls controls over internal
procedures and the division's
organizational structure were inadequate
statute established four expected
outcomes to optimize profitability
ensure proper control
operate efficiently and effectively and
provide customer service
in practice performance management
centered on quantifying how many times
certain tasks were accomplished not on
whether the right task was accomplished
how well a task was accomplished or
whether expected outcomes were achieved
performance management controls were
inadequate
division practices were neither
objectively shown to be capable of
producing expected outcomes nor able to
demonstrate what outcomes were actually
produced
there were no analyses to objectively
allocate personnel and allocations
skewed towards the use of sworn law
enforcement personnel including for
numerous administrative tasks
over 61 percent of all division
positions were allocated to sworn
employees
knowledge management is the control
system over collecting recording and
analyzing quality data and producing and
using knowledge
however knowledge management practices
were inadequate controls were fragmented
and improvised practices produced
inaccurate incomplete and unreliable
records
chapter 2 addresses licensing
we found licensing controls lacked a
discernible design and were reliant upon
ad hoc rules
practices were inconsistent with statute
rules and sops
licensing was complex to the point where
a pre-application form and process had
to be used before an applicant should
begin the actual license application
process
simplifying licensing has received
attention in the past but that objective
was unrealized while there were over 100
licensed types and subtypes they all fit
into three basic categories
our recommendations here include the
commission seeking risk-based licensing
reforms to simplify the licensing
framework
chapter three addresses the direct
shipper program
the program was created to enable
citizens and licensees to buy hard to
find alcoholic beverages from
out-of-state suppliers
but the program's controls lacked a
discernible design
the program's statutory purpose was
exceeded
statutory non-compliance was
long-standing ad hoc rulemaking was
common
rules were inconsistently followed and
prior audit findings were unresolved
the division inconsistently enforced
compliance and sanctioned non-compliance
ultimately the commission did not know
what was being directly shipped into the
state or whether the correct amount of
taxes and fees were received
chapter 4 addresses the examination
function
we found examination processes lacked a
discernible design
the division could not demonstrate
expected
related outcomes were achieved with 92
percent of licensees not receiving an
examination during our two-year audit
period
rules and sops were inadequate
practices were reliant upon broad ad-hoc
rulemaking and were non-compliant with
statute
examination processes were known to rely
on outmoded inefficient practices
chapter 5 addresses enforcement
we found controls to ensure licensee
compliance with laws and rules were
inadequate and lacked a discernible
design
prior audit findings were not addressed
and long-standing deficiencies and waste
persisted
some enforcement activities were
unrelated to a licensee or permittee or
were without connection to statutes for
which the commission was responsible
this scope creep was a long-standing
unresolved concern
scope creep was not due to changes to
statute or rules but instead was a
management choice
it undermined the achievement of
expected outcomes
the subject of extra jurisdictional
activities was where we had the most
significant disagreements with the
commission and is more fully discussed
in observation number 38 and in appendix
c
additionally elective training education
and outreach were not shown to achieve
expected outcomes
controls to prevent unlicensed or
unpermitted possession or transfer of
alcoholic beverages and controls over
adulteration and misbranding were
inadequate
premises inspection practices were
inconsistently effective with more than
41 percent of licensees not receiving a
regulatory visit during our two-year
audit period
nearly 32 percent of the inspections
that were conducted were excessive
for example one licensee received 35
inspections from six different
investigators over two years without a
recorded liquor law violation
compliance check operations did not
efficiently and effectively ensure
proper control and were not risk-based
controls over complaints investigations
and sanctions were inadequate
our recommendations here include
migrating extra jurisdictional
activities to a law enforcement agency
and constraining division activities to
its role as a regulatory agency
current division management in place
since april 2017 did not create the
defective controls we identified many
defects were long-standing
nonetheless management was responsible
for effective and efficient operation
and reported undertaking a review of
internal practices identifying some of
the same issues we identified
a holistic approach to management
control could help ensure the issues we
identify will be fully remediated and
remain effectively controlled
developing such controls including a
risk-based data informed strategy and
supporting plans with detailed
implementing procedures will likely take
a substantial amount of time and effort
without these underpinnings division
efforts to manage change run the risk of
occurring in isolation without obtaining
measurable improvements and achieving
expected outcomes
i would like to thank the commission
staff and numerous stakeholders for
their assistance during this audit and
unless there are any questions for me i
will be followed by chairman malika
are there any questions from anyone on
the committee
representative
so this is about
chapter three the direct shipper program
um looking through it appears that most
of the concerns
have to do with uh
you know whether or not
u.s cities are being followed and
whether or not uh
no rules and laws are being enforced
um
and then there was some comment about
customer service but was there
to get any information
on how effectively
um they're able to meet the needs of uh
customers for specialty things
in particular there's a couple of uh
restaurants in my district one who i've
talked
where they've had chronic problems on
getting particular things uh through the
program they uh
kind of a specialty restaurant and they
stock some things i mean
they sell some things that aren't
normally
carrying the liquor store and it's been
a real problem for us but was that
covered in this
representative it is not covered in this
uh what our chapter three addresses are
the control frameworks that the
commission has put in place to ensure
that proper control
occurred
that
the controls were
optimized profitability and that in that
context
customer service was rendered so whether
a permittee received a permit timely and
that would be a direct shipper permittee
not necessarily somebody that was
seeking a hard to find item
whether they the permittee received
their permit timely and that there was
equitable resolution to their
application for a permit to ship into
the state
so we did not look at the
ultimate
end user or customer
whether the individual citizen or
whether it was a licensee
[Music]
that's right we focused on the shipper
end of things because they were the ones
that held a permit to ship
thank you madam chair
this is a question for either uh mr
grady or mr smith can you tell us
briefly um what is the purpose of the
new hampshire liquor store and the
commissioner what are their ultimate
goals and what are the expected outcomes
right well i'll take that representative
statute establishes four expected
outcomes
for the commission one
is to optimize profitability two is to
ensure proper control
three is to operate efficiently and
effectively and four is to provide
customer service
follow up please and chair
um so
how does um
tax revenue and um
you know the the purpose of the i would
think the purpose of all these state
liquor stores is to generate because we
could have private stores right so what
kind of revenue are we expect is the
state expected to receive from this
commission
well we did not audit the larger
commission and its retail operations we
focused on its division of enforcement
and licensing which was responsible for
narrow subset of the commission's
revenues
thank you so much it's very helpful yes
ma'am representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
uh mr grady how long have you been with
uh the lba
since 1997.
since 1997. thank you so i have a
follow-up question um
i've been on relevant question please
thank you um
so i i've been on the committee for 15
years and one of the things that that
i've noted is that
in previous iterations
uh the
lba has
uh found deficiencies
uh and
the um the
deficiencies were
noted as
long-standing and unaddressed
before beginning your audit did you
review the previous uh
the previous audit that had been done
yes representative we did we reviewed a
number of them in fact thank you and and
did you uh
in on discovering that those decisions
reported that there was only one of the
21 observations from previous audits
that had actually been closed
yes uh thank you uh so
when you reviewed the the
previous audit
uh and noted that deficiency still
existed did you query the person you
were dealing with as to what plans they
had to
address the previously unaddressed
deficiencies
we did representative yes
okay thank you representative burroughs
yes thank you for taking my question um
mr grady um was it within your purview
to uh make recommendations regarding um
changes in management
for the functions that you were
reviewing
we did not uh take that into
consideration or did we make any
recommendations along those lines
follow follow-up please follow-up
i'm can i just i'm just trying to
understand why is that
we are not in a position as external
auditors to recommend personnel changes
we look at
how the agency has
built a system to control its operations
thank you very much
yes ma'am are there other questions yes
representing scitec well uh you said
this has to do with uh enforcement and
licensing this particular audit whether
it be is there a contemplated audit of
the retail side
we currently do not have a audit topic
of the retail operations of the
commission
no
thank you other questions
all right thank you very much
so you said that chairman malaka wishes
to speak i believe he does
okay commissioner malika
hey good morning madam chair mr chairman
members of the committee
with me is our ceo rose wyatt our chief
of enforcement mark armagenian our cfo
tina demers deputy chief scott dunn
lieutenant danielle elston and
lieutenant matt calver
if i may the new hampshire liquor
commission has thoroughly analyzed the
lda
performance audit of the division of
enforcement and licensing for the time
period july 17 through
july i'm sorry july 1st 17 through july
30th 19.
as with any audit
the audit is a snapshot in time and does
not represent the substantial efforts
undertaken
by the division of enforcement to
streamline and improve
its processes over the past three years
of the audit findings
80 percent
are partially
substantially or fully complete
only 20 percent remain open but each has
been examined and a specific timeline
has been established for each of its
completion
the new hampshire liquor commission has
a comprehensive plan in place
led by our chief of enforcement and
chief operating officer to resolve the
remainder of these items in the near
future
some of which will need rural and
legislative change
and with that being said
we'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you madam chair mr chairman
members of the committee
thank you i i saw that that corrective
action plan and
i was
wondering when you will be making your
next report to the legislature
we'll be at the fiscal committee on a
monthly basis
madam chair until all those are resolved
and of which 80 percent are partially
substantially or fully complete but we
will be in front of fiscal every month
until those are resolved
excellent thank you very much
thank you madam chair
representatives
and you know you're muted you're muted
and you
sorry about that i'm going to pose the
same question that i did or to mr grady
which is um does the commissioner feel
that there need to be any personnel
changes as a result of the
recommendations made um by the audit
well
uh representative a few years ago the
liquor commission underwent
what i i would consider substantial
personnel changes we were switched from
a three commission agency to one
chairman and a deputy commissioner we
run the agency with just three
divisions
and um i'm sure you know but the net
profit for the liquor commission this
year versus prior is up 14.7 percent or
13.9 million and in the past 10 years
the sales of the liquor commission has
increased by over 200 million dollars i
think that everyone uh on the call sees
along with their constituents what the
liquor commission has done to develop
and refine a brand over the last 10
years we took stores from the corner dog
legs
of plazas we've created a brand we've
created a look and feel
fifty percent of our business comes from
cross border sales so people come to new
hampshire to buy wine and spirits much
like they do many other things our
prices are nationally recognized
and the liquor commission has been been
named the best control state in the
nation the past two years running we
clearly have a brand and we clearly are
a profitable business the enforcement
division
is a division of that and obviously uh
the audit has found some some findings
which we would consider substantial as
well but we would also uh like to remind
the committees that 80
are partially substantially or fully
complete and we look to complete the
other 20
in the upcoming years again some of
which will need law and some of which
will need rule change
thank you
thank you welcome
thank you madam chair
um
mr monica you just stated that
new hampshire liquor commission was
named best in the nation in certain
categories who
proclaimed that
there's a magazine that does the control
states uh representative it's called
market watch it's kind of the benchmark
for the liquor industry they also own
several other uh
several several other magazines that are
out of new york city so they're a
nationally recognized magazine called
market watch
follow up madam chair follow up
thank you um
and did uh representatives of this
magazine or any of the others come and
do
any type of auditing of your activities
uh they're not in the business of
auditing the liquor commission uh
representative they are in the business
of looking at us from a retailer rep
respect so they come in and look at what
we've done the level of sales how
they've increased the profitability
of the liquor commission which is up 5.2
percent
of this year and
and how we uh
the look and feel of our stores the look
and feel of our brand the customer
service provided by our associates in
the stores the brands that we represent
the skus that are in our store the
square footage that we have
so they look at us from a retailer
standpoint
and that's what we are we are a business
and we are a retailer and we are a
business that runs within the confines
of state government
thank you representative hunt
thank you madam chairman um
chairman um the issue they're saying
some of these issues are need to be
solved legislatively and certainly we've
had legislation every year and we try to
you know work in terms of the commission
can you give me of this these
recommendations the top three
legislative recommendations that uh you
recommend me going forward and and i do
know that we have a direct shipping bill
senate bill 125 that's coming over to us
anyways but i'm not sure whether that's
in there but what are the issues
of justin for the division that that you
think legislatively
we can and should fix
good morning uh rosemary wyatt i'm the
director of administration um and i i
worked with the division to put together
the corrective plan so
to address your question um
representative the
one of the first things you'll see that
we have planned is reviewing the
strategic plan that's in place
um and
looking at that critically and building
out measurable objectives from that as
recommended in
the in the audit report
a component of that is also to
at that time really identify and
consider what legislative
changes we would seek
one so
i i we can't specifically answer your
question at this time but what i can
offer that might be of assistance
is
some of the recommendations probably the
biggest recommendation that came out of
the report was around simplifying
the um
the statutory the structure
both in terms of statute and the rules
so i think that would be the overall
focus as we look at this
and one of the things i'd like to add
mister thank you
one of the things i'd like to add mr
chairman is something that we've spoke
about in the past is looking at the
license structure for the for the state
of new hampshire which is uh
then
for lack of a better way to put it put
together
through a number of years obviously the
commission has been in place since 1934.
there's been carve-outs in the licensing
there's been things that have been asked
the commission has been asked to do with
special licenses and all of us feel that
the license structure is too broad and
too bifurcated we'd like to be able to
look at that as time goes on
change our licensing structure from we
have 100 licenses chief
48 licenses down to perhaps a dozen and
we'd like to be able to to look at that
uh legislatively uh
through committee in order to change
that we we also know that there's a lot
of things that the commission does
on from a licensing standpoint
that as uh mr grady and mr smith have
said
that have maybe grown over the years and
can certainly be
[Music]
can be can be qualified and
consolidated
well
as someone who has been around
actually sponsored one of those changes
and had my head handed to me on the
miles floor on that on the bill to trade
recordification because it had wasn't
explained to them about why
we ended up doing having a hundred
different licenses like an obscure
license on a
a private tennis court that they had to
have two tennis courts uh they did and
didn't have the food requirement where
others might have
made was that explained to them that
each one of those unique licenses was a
carve out in unique in in itself and
that's the reason why you know the the
ruler did not even need rule making but
that would all the
the the fee for instance the reason why
the fees are varied because each one had
a different what do we think was the
right fee
and that's how they were you know such
and so you know not just not just the
fact that we have all these hundred
licenses but we have all these different
fees that are related to that license
and was that explained to them that that
to try to reshuffle you're not going to
change it you're still going to have all
these sub categories
you you're just going to maybe you know
say oh this is a one kind of license and
we did that with the sport facility
license that that
you're really not going to solve
anything when you just all you're doing
is re-codifying and calling it something
different even though at the end of the
day they're all going to still have to
have their individual fees and their
individual rules about what was that
license was created for
uh respectfully mr chairman uh uh and
with all due respect to the lba
that was not the concern of the audit
and when those types of things were
brought forward as part of the audit
those
those weren't taken into consideration
the nuances the legislative changes what
has been done for
uh constituents as certain things come
up licenses change for your uh example
a tennis court license an expansion of
service
uh a catering license
uh
a license that would have to do with uh
you know a business that has multiple
bars or multiple locations all of those
things have evolved as the liquor
business has evolved
when we had just
one license for one establishment that
did business one way
uh
you know maybe that was uh 25 35 40
years ago we now have entrepreneurs and
i was one in the state for 15 years and
in other states for 15 that have uh that
have ideas about how their businesses
should run and how their businesses
should look so we can't
narrowly define licensure in in any
particular aspect we have to be flexible
along with the businesses and as they
change we need to change that's why
these types of licenses have been
brought forth and when i say mr chairman
that we need to evolve what we do i say
that respectfully to
what the what the legislature has asked
us to do over the years because we
recognize that this has grown to a point
where perhaps we could codify some of
these licenses and put some of these
things into a structure that would be uh
more feasible for people to understand
and and not
have to have a certain knowledge of the
business it's uh it's certainly a vast
structure but
mr mr chairman it works and that's why
it is the way it is
thank you representative pearson
thank you manager i have a
couple questions that are going to
depend upon the the answer i get
uh looking looking over at enforcement
uh in chapter five
in the area of page 250.
the enforcement officers within the
commission did they work out of their
homes or they were required to come into
an office in order to start their day as
an inspector
um i could answer that for your
representative it's uh mark armagenian
um
director of uh enforcement and licensing
twofold uh first and foremost um they
are
contractually
on duty if you will
from the point that they leave their
houses
we put our employees
in their geographic areas to be more
fiscally responsible so we don't have
enforcement
investigators
driving
crisscrossing each other driving all
over the state instead of
regulating in their
geographic areas just to cut out fuel
costs
but there are
the nucleus of the enforcement division
and they have desks that are assigned to
them are right here in liquor commission
headquarters
thank you okay so
look at looking at the excessive
enforcement side of this thing where
we're looking at 31 of the
of the places that were never inspected
versus 31 of the excessive inspections
is there any correlation between the
places that are excessively inspected
and the locations of your inspectors
where they start their day
absolutely so if i could just take a
step back to give you a uh
a good picture of what has occurred here
this audit itself has started two months
after i walked in the door to assess
this division with the new command step
that we have put together
in that two-month period we did an
assessment that lasted seven months not
an audit but an assessment to see where
we have fallen short as a division what
we need to fix and it all came down to
processes
and the efficiency and effectiveness of
this division
so we at that time and it's a very good
point representative burroughs also
brought up a good point um
we were at 41
we are now which is outside of
the audit time it was not documented we
are now at 100
and for some reason that just does not
resonate through everybody that we keep
telling this to
we are a new division
75 percent of this command staff is new
and changed
from myself on through to the frontline
supervisors
we have redone our licensing
unit to be more customer friendly and
our basis here was education right from
the get-go
and those were conversations that i had
had with representatives when i walked
in the door that expressed to me some of
the concerns that were going on that we
took into account and started fixing the
problem here is they are outside of this
window that occurred two months into me
walking in the door
one more question thank you very much
okay
looking at the breakup of of how you
how you assign your inspectors according
to this report cheshire and sullivan
counties
neither of which i represent
um if you appear to have no assigned
inspector whatsoever leaving that
requirement for
i would presume the surrounding areas
with your plan being what appears to be
a geographical
um
a geographical assignment basis
have you read since this audit have you
restructured a little bit to provide
those counties with an inspector that's
dedicated or you was your intention to
continue to operate under
what has happened that are meeting here
in this audit
so thank you for your question
representative twofold number one every
county in this state is covered by a
permanent investigator
every licensee knows who their
investigator is personally
and if there is a an issue it is dealt
with at the lowest level if it has to
rise up through
it it does so but but know this also
we've restructured the whole command
structure here
that our frontline supervisors are not
just sitting at a desk
supervising or correcting reports
when we dropped from 29 investigators
down to 21 we had to restructure we had
to repurpose
what we do for a daily
our daily duties
so our frontline supervisors actually
are the support mechanism on the road
for
not only
enforcing the rules of title 13 or the
laws of title 13 and the rules that that
are assigned to us but they are also
there
as teachers to educate and do mts
training
lots training
teams training to servers throughout the
state
and and they also cover an area
um whether whether it's doing an audit
or an inspection
um they they are multifaceted and and
nobody has just one hat that they would
all the way up to myself
thank you
representative mccaller
um you
uh mr mullica you you said that i think
it was this marketing magazine out of
new york uh ranked you number third
um is ranking you number third
against uh private enterprises i mean
you sort of run the uh the liquor
commission as a private business i
understand or were you ranked against
uh other state uh
entities now i'm sort of interested
in who you might consider
uh
you know sort of a competition uh a a
business or state run similar to new
hampshire and what their profitability
might be
compared to ours
representative i have all the data that
i'd be happy to provide you that shows
uh how we rank in in
consideration with the other control
states we were we are ranked in that
magazine and in others
as
against private businesses as well and
our our number one competitor in the
united states is total wide
they're the largest
retailer in the united states beverage
wine and spirit retailer they also do
beer and cigars
they are in 26 states
they have about
198 to 201 stores depending on what you
read
they have about 1700 employees and in
2017 they opened between 2016 and 17
they opened six stores in the state of
massachusetts when licensing had changed
there so
that's as high up in the states as they
are they have a few stores in
connecticut as well a couple in new york
a few in in
new jersey but they're they're the
largest competitor and we we don't rank
ourselves against other control states
because each control state model is
different the only other control state
that does the wholesale and the retail
much like we do would be pennsylvania
and we are we they are a larger state
obviously we are we've been ranked the
number one profitable control state
and uh
in putting ourselves against total wine
as competition that's that's sort of the
benchmark where we need to be and where
we are we saw a little dip in business
in 2016 and 17 when they opened six
stores in massachusetts inside the 495
belt
directly
putting their footprint against our our
business model but we've rebounded and
obviously the ship the sales this year
show it that our uh you know our revenue
breakdown versus prior year is that
we're up 14.7 this year
obviously a lot of our business comes
from cross-border so we advertise
cross-border
and we promote cross-border we're not
here
just to serve the folks inside the state
of new hampshire because that would be
limiting our market
obviously new hampshire is our primary
focus but with 50 percent of our
business coming from outside of new
hampshire we need to be a retailer
that's competitive in all those
surrounding states 23 plus percent of
our business does come from
massachusetts alone
thank you representative
thank you madam chair
um
i
i'm gonna go back to the
the tax revenue because
when people from new hampshire see the
liquor stores
and they see people buying them
they translate that to tax income they
don't transfer the liquor commission as
an entrepreneurial business
however
if you consider yourself that and
apparently you are considered that
within the state every business has
protocol that they have to follow
so
i'd like to know why
or in the past have you met with the
fiscal committee to discuss previouses
to discuss previous issues with your
audits
and
why were those not fixed
and what can you do what can you say to
us
that will assure us that your monthly
meetings with the fiscal committee is
going to resolve the issues
well uh representative i can't speak to
the previous audits because i was not
here when those audits were brought
forth
and uh quite frankly i had no knowledge
of the of the audits
failures as as they were spoke about
from mr grady in this audit but i can
assure you
in my 35 years as an entrepreneur i've
never failed at anything
and i don't intend to fail at this
i've grown the liquor commission along
with the team that we have here by 200
million dollars in the last 10 years so
i think from our entrepreneurial
standpoint we're not measured against
what happens here in new hampshire we're
measured what happens around the world
we are a worldwide retailer we have
products from all over the world that
are shipped into the state from a tax
revenue standpoint is just a very small
piece of what we do we're a revenue
generating business
and in going back to what the fiscal
committee has now asked us to do as part
of their resolve is to come back every
month and let them know how we are doing
with this we did that last week and we
gave them the numbers that we brought in
front of you the 80 of these findings
are partially substantially or fully
complete and only 20 remain open
i can assure you that we will do
everything in our power to
bring this audit to a close as quickly
as we possibly can
please let him cheer i'll follow up
so what you're saying to me is at the
new hampshire liquor store
based on what you just said to me new
hampshire the state of new hampshire is
in the liquor business is that what
you're saying
the state of new hampshire is absolutely
in the beverage wine business and liquor
business yes ma'am it is
thank you representative burrows and you
don't have to keep raising your hand i'm
the one that's lowering it and that's
because i've already noted that you wish
to you have a question
okay thank you um i i wasn't sure why
that was happening um
the the report states that inefficiency
compromised the optimization of
profitability and to tie into the the
previous question about entrepreneurship
i'm wondering and i don't know the
answer to this do this does the state
allow a salary in certain certain
positions to be tied to both uh
profitability and revenue are you
allowed to do that
we do not have a bonus system in place
uh representative follow please follow
up
um is that do you know do would you know
whether that's permissible by law
governor lynch uh put we put something
in house bill 2 back in 2010 or 2011
that allowed the liquor commission to
look at the possibility
of
promoting that type of
revenue generation for our employees in
the stores
there was a number set on it i believe
it was 50 000 that could be shared among
employees i'd have to look back at the
full details of it representative to
speak with some certainty on it
thank you
thank you madam chair
uh mr uh maliki what percentage of whole
sales sales come from out of state and
how many of these are cash sales
that's those are wholesale we don't do
any wholesale out of
just retail out of state
and we don't we don't necessarily track
out of state sales other than we do zip
code surveys which allows us to find
where people are coming from from other
states to buy in our stores so all our
all our
data that shows out of state sales has
been done from zip code surveys
with our consumers
and follow-up madam chair
a few years ago there was issues
in certain stores regarding
hennessy sales and
many of these sales were cash
transactions and many of these people
were from out of state can you explain
that to me
well
those rules are governed by the irs
representative and anyone that spends
more than ten thousand dollars in cash
in our stores is required at this point
to fill out an irs form if the sales are
under ten thousand dollars in their cash
or if they're over ten thousand dollars
in their credit uh no form is required
that's an irs requirement
all right thank you welcome
representative
thank you madam chair
so mr chairman uh
one of the things i always look at first
with a performance audit is
whether there is legislation required
to address the issue
because that's partly on us
so
in this case i think there are 11 which
would require legislative action are you
currently
working with one or more of
the legislature uh to uh to address
those issues
our representative at this point as
we're going through the findings uh
ceo wyan and the chief are looking at
what would be needed and what
legislative or rule changes would be
necessary and we will have a better
handle on that in the upcoming months
but we have a number of representatives
and
senators in the state that do take an
interest in bringing those types of
legislation forward that do have a
background
with the liquor commission and
understanding what we do and we'd
certainly be willing to uh bring it to
those uh representatives and or senators
uh when we feel that the time is right
and we have these changes in place that
we feel could make us
more efficient
okay well as they say that's on us so
it's good to know you're working on it
thank you thank you representative
representative
thank you madam chair so on page 10 of
the um
please jackie i can't hear you oh of
course is this better i'll increase my
sound
um
on page 10 of the audit report
there are internal control comments
there are comments from the audit
and there are 12 of these um
uh comments from
various parts of the report
that are in process these are the 12
that you're reviewing with the fiscal
committee is that correct
well what we're doing
representative is
if i understand your question is we're
bringing
the whole audit
back to the fiscal committee and and
letting them know what we've completed i
would imagine
that there will be a follow-up audit of
enforcement to make sure that these uh
findings
and things that we have completed are
further reviewed
follow up
you do
real you do understand what part of the
audit i'm referring to page 10 and 11
which has the
status of the findings of the audit
whether or not they've been
completed or whether or not they're they
have not been completed and of the 12
that are not completed from 2018 to 2019
12 of them are in process so what
priority do they have among the things
that all of you do in your business
how do these 12
points that need to be addressed how do
they fit into the priority and are they
going to be discussed with this operator
specific they're very specific things
well i'm i'm having a little trouble
hearing your representative but
everything
question can you hear me now
i can
i'm sorry that you couldn't hear me
before
on page 10 and 11 of the audit report
there are 12
process
remediations
i would like to know and those are the
crux of the audit report those are the
things that
were supposed to be addressed
to be addressed as a result of the audit
where do those 12
process those 12 remediations fall in
line with your priorities
and where when will that and will that
be addressed with the fiscal committee
these are very the 12 very specific
things
representative have you examined the
report of corrective action that was
sent out
[Music]
because i believe that covers much of
your question
okay thank you
representative
uh thank you madam chair and this
question concerns the uh
extrovert jurisdictional enforcement
section in particular
ages
231-242 i understand that um
that you took over and put in place you
know management team uh recently
so my question is um
does the agency response to this section
reflect um your views or
was that put together
before you were involved
thank you for your question
representative
um these
uh
these observations
uh the answers to them are our views
today
um know that
not only do we have rules administrative
rules that cover
are as you do know
our our
daily duties
but we have laws that need law
enforcement jurisdiction to actually
follow through with a majority of them
need law enforcement jurisdiction to do
so with with that in mind when we
regulate we only regulate to the point
of your community's safety
we don't there there has been some rumor
and innuendo out there that says that
we're over regulating or though that is
stuff that i we walked in the door
listening to
that has all changed to a point of
creating an environment of education we
believe compliance comes with education
so good people trip every day of the
week
we believe that in educating them we get
corresponding compliance out of them
which creates a
safe environment for the licensees
patrons and it also creates a safe
environment for the communities that
possibly these these negative instances
that are around the use of alcohol
in over service could could incur
so with that in mind
uh yes this is
this is truly the
uh answer that was done by this
administration
um i had more in mind the question um
you know extra jurisdiction of course
and things that are arguably arguably uh
not directly related to
the job of the liquor commission that's
part one and the other part is i'm
looking at your corrective action plan
for uh item 38.
in the comments and elsewhere in here
there's uh
references to things like a dash 101 and
that's whatever
what are those references too and where
would i find them
so the you're referring i think you're
referring to policy
um
and and that would be actually an
internal document here at the liquor
commission
but also recognize that the
disagreement on extra jurisdictional was
more we didn't disagree on whether or
not the division should be doing that
stuff we disagreed on the jurisdictional
point of it
that it was things that were outside of
our mission
but
within our jurisdictional realm and to
to be honest about it are those
um other things that we have done
in this uh this short snapshot of time
the duties that we have performed
um we're only looking at six instances
that fell outside of our jurisdiction
around
that were life safety issues that had to
have intervention
there was a necessity for intervention
at that point and one right off the bat
was one of our investigators was at a
stoplight and had a woman passed out
behind the wheel of her car that was uh
actually if i'm not mistaken overdosing
on fentanyl
that investigator had to get involved in
that
there was no other recourse to that and
these are the things that are being
documented here that just
i i'm not saying that they're
misrepresented because they are what
they are they're just
when you drill down and get into the
weeds on them there's a different
perspective on it
thank you thank you
i have one one comment
the
response to observation 38 says there's
a difference of interpretation of the
statute and the statutory duties
would you make sure to include in your
legislative changes
a clarification of the statute
from your position
so that it can be
debated and approved by the legislature
or disapproved and we can settle this
interpretational issue
with
and get it
off the audit books
definitely represent madam chair uh
thank you for that comment we will also
provide case law
um to not only superior court but
supreme court that we've had cases that
have actually been
decided at those highest levels
with cases that we have dealt with
with the licensees so we can definitely
provide all that
thank you the the issue with case law is
that those of us who are not lawyers are
not familiar with looking at it we
prefer to have it in statute
very well
that will happen thank you
are there any other questions from
anyone on the committee
how efficient of us
uh is there anyone else who wishes to
speak
on this audit
seeing none thank you all
i believe we will be asking for a copy
of the report to the fiscal committee
in order to evaluate the corrective
actions
but other than that do we have any other
activities that need to be done in joint
committee
all right thank you very much and i'll
close the action on the on the top
yes thank you i see that
thank you chairman hunt and members of
the commerce commission committee for
joining us
and for your questions and we will
we are eagerly awaiting the results of
the next meeting
next report from the liquor commission
well thank you for inviting us we
appreciate it and uh it's my first time
ever going through one of these since
it was very interesting
thank you
thank you madam chair mr chairman
members of the committee thank you very
much
have a great day
thank you
yeah we'll take a short break while all
our visitors leave and then edna will
resume with an executive session at
quarter after
um pardon me madam chair that's on do we
remain on this link if with the dna
yes you do this this link will just be
carried on through for the edna um
public hearing and execs thank you
sure
exciting just over staff that's part of
my
kind of criticism
somebody
who got just my attention
it didn't contribute to the decision or
the thing it just felt more trustworthy
[Music]
because all positions within the
state system
yeah the problem is that the jobs are so
different that it really you're not
going to you're not going to have a guy
that's
you know you know you know
as it is professionally the same
excuse me edna i'm going to just mute
the room um so you'll need to remember
to unmute when you're ready
you all we have
uh
today and wednesday we're reading and i
hope that we can exact all of our house
skills
so that we will not have to come back a
week after
okay so
representative goalie you have an
amendment to house bill 533
division of investigation appliance from
the lottery commission
representative goalie was charged with
making
making it grammatical and sensible
yes
yes thank you madam chair uh i'd like to
offer amendment 0906h
second
you wish you speak to your amendment
uh the amendment goes over uh changing
some of the clarifications that we
discussed um during the hearing um
with discussion with
folks over at lottery this is in the uh
racing statute so as we discussed about
changing racing um that was not advised
that we leave the word racing in there
goes down and also changes on line
to the 45 days after
the initiation of the investigation
versus the receipt of the request
um
this is all in
working with john conforti who is the
with the
lottery commission
i believe he's chief of chief
investigator
um
also
goes down to
change
on line 24 the original bill had said
the attorney general and stopped there
um we added back in in the lottery
commission
so both the attorney general and
laundering commission shall confer and
determine if in their opinion and um
little discussion went on about um i
know i received an email from
representative bailey not liking uh the
word fit or not fit
this is the word they came up with for
replacement was
suitable and suitability
and then we just cleaned up the last
section of the statue going down through
27 through the end of the bill
it was just kind of redundant so we
combined those two last two sentences
into one
and with that i'd be glad to take any
questions
or concerns
represent pearson
i think about your with the
this amendment is
this considered a rewrite
yes it is okay because the bottom of
this amendment has nothing to do it
mentions no um nothing about an
effective date or or anything like that
that's correct it only replaces section
two of the bill
section three on rulemaking
and section four on the effective date
are not affected by the amendments
okay so this yeah okay so this is not
this is amending the bill but it's not a
full rewrite i got you that's correct
okay thank you all right anyone else
thank you representative schuett do you
wish to speak on your second
um i will just say that
i think
all members of the committee recognize
during the hearing
when representative goalie pointed out
these various items that they did need
fixing
does anyone else wish to speak on the
bill around the amendment
all right seeing none the motion is to
approve amendment
0906 to house bill 533
and the third
on the amendment representative right
yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes
representative santa mustafa
yes
representative
yes representative judy
representing judy going twice
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
representative follows
yes
representative
[Music]
we
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair yes
i believe that's 18 to 0.
okay excellent for some goalie do you
have a motion
yes manager i'll move i have to pass
with amendment
second
i'll second
okay
hey
do you wish to say anything wrong
has
covered everything
all right represents pearson
no we've covered it well thank you
anyone else
thank you in that case the motion is
ought to pass with amendment on house
bill 533
and
when ready the clerk will call the rules
representative wright yes reference
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative lanzara yes
representative
yes
representative thunk now yes
representative
yes representative o'brien
yes
chair yes
does anyone object to consent
on house bill 187 representative pearson
you have a a motion
i'd like to move amendment
0629 h
second
what was that please
[Music]
yes
all right you shall speak to your
amendment i want to thank you madam
chair
when health and human services had this
bill originally they they really kind of
focused on some some of the other areas
and one of the things that
they kind of really honestly according
to the chairman slipped through the
crack was they the oversight
and the review of the orders
by the chairman
and excuse me the commissioner of health
and human services
um there was in in the original
legislation
it was a pretty pretty good reduction of
that oversight committee
in discussions with
various folks that were
honestly unaware they were even being
removed
it became pretty evident that if the
if the commissioner of health and human
services is going to issue in a a
directive or
an order
that
realistically the folks that are going
to
most likely carry that type of a health
order out
and when i say that it's one of the
boots on the ground folks really should
probably be on that advisory committee
to
be able to
discuss and
and uh advise whether or not the the
order that's coming out is practical to
to actually do it so i i can like you
can imagine that the chaos if the
if health and human services
director issue issued an emergency order
and then the boots on the ground all
rose up and said hey we can't actually
implement this so it's not a good look
for the state it's it's just not good
public policy and
and frankly it uh
we can we can head this all off so
this was uh in discussions with the
chairman of health and human services
and their ranking member or the vice
chair
they uh they both didn't have an issue
with this restoring a couple of these
spots at all
the reason the county representative was
not restored is because after
discussions with those stakeholders the
county really doesn't
um
supply anything
to this action so
the the
the
they felt that the county representative
really served no purpose
on this so that's why
just to
answer the question ahead of time that's
why the county representative was not
was not restored here
is involving do you wish to add
something
no i think representative pearson
explained it very well
all right excellent
is there any further discussion
representative
thank you madam chairman uh so i have
some reservations with it
with regard to this issue
uh first of all uh i think it the
the concept violates
our rules that no committee or
subcommittee of the house can bind the
house
and this would be a joint committee
so it would be
binding the entire legislature
it may be that under certain
circumstances uh
such an action is warranted i understand
that it
requires effectively a four-fifths vote
of the uh
of the committee
um
i also
uh am troubled by the idea that you may
have
people who are primarily politicians
uh
deciding uh
something
that is beyond their
their expertise
being quite quote-unquote just
politicians
so uh
to the degree that people are
technicians in their private lives
doctors lawyers
i don't mean lawyers doctors nurses
people who have knowledge of
medical things
so
as i say i have i think it's
fundamentally flawed with regard to the
subcommittee or committee aspect
violating our rules
but also the makeup of the committee
would have to be something where they
are getting involved
with overriding a decision of a
commissioner who ideally should be
something of an expert
uh in the field
of hhs
uh and
historically have been
uh somebody who was background in that
field
so anyway that those are my uh can
my reservations about proceeding with
this uh with this issue at all
chair representative pearson can i
remind representative schmidt that this
is an oversight advisory committee and
that is all that it is
it's justified
thank you
isn't it the case that they can
basically with a four-fifths vote
uh rescind the commissioner's order
all right yes i believe that's still
there on page uh
page two almost the way down
representative roy
um i just had a question regarding the
county thing the sheriff's departments
would have any
assistance in this yeah
okay yeah so what would happen within
the sheriff's department the sheriff's
department would end up
falling under
whichever
law enforcement agency was the lead on
this and they would be brought in with
them
so that it's not a county necessarily a
county thing because you would have a
joint law enforcement
action i only asked the budgetary side
of it
would there be an expense to the county
by them being
deputized for a lack of better term into
a bigger law enforcement effort
i you know i mean i the state already
has a procedure
for that as far as like if the state
police bring in uh a joint task force
and stuff so i would i would presume
that it would fall under the same
guidelines that they do already
just follow them follow um
did you consult with the counties and
they said we really don't
i can tell you we're rocking him
accountable yeah so they so we're good
well because the the rocky at least
rockingham county has never actually
even gone to the table with us they've
never been involved and because their
their role was
we don't we don't provide anything so
you know
um concerned with the surprise budgetary
in fact that's all well i mean typically
too when you look at
this this level of
you know when an action like this is
taken it's done under a declared action
by the
by the state so at that point you have
those other things that kick in
um
reimbursement that's what i'm looking
for from a reimbursement standpoint
chair
yes does
does representative schmidt have a point
with violating our rules
it is a concern that
a committee of the legislature cannot
bind
the entire legislature
so in this case i would say that
this oversight committee
part that says it's subject to review is
fine there's no question about that
but the rescinded by a vote of the
committee is as representative pointed
out not
normally good practice
and
i don't know if it's explicitly against
our rules
but it's
but but if we have
additional
uh oversight over
executive orders which will be in house
built 417 which is coming up next
and that would qualify and this would
just be an advice it would be a
a recession that would be
subject to
approval or disapproval by the
entire legislature
and keep in mind too this was this made
it through the house once with less than
10 people voting against it so it was
clearly a bipartisan uh
desire for this to i'm just concerned
that if he's right i don't want to i
don't want to set a bad precedent
i think the point is that it
the review is
perfectly appropriate
and if they think it's that bad they
could probably convince the rest of the
house
so i would
yes representative schmidt
until they do this this this says they
can rescind
uh you and i are on the gel car you know
that we can't even we can't stop uh
and
a proposed rule by ourselves uh uh uh
the
uh the required motion
has to be subsequently
uh approved by both house and senate uh
for the um
for that uh
action of the jail car to be upheld and
and it's can be completely legitimate uh
that something should not go forward but
even as powerful and well-established
committee as the jail car cannot do it
by itself and i think this says it says
we sin uh i don't i think we have to
check with the clerk uh before we can
proceed this i i don't think this flies
under our rules
all right i tend to agree with you
representative schmidt i will confirm
that the clerk and see if this is
allowed
um
i'd like to go through with the vote on
the amendment which does not affect this
paragraph first
and then we will
recess until wednesday
thank you i appreciate that
madam chair question representative
thank you um
we normally only will put forward one
amendment on a bill
and i'm wondering if we should not defer
on this amendment
if the clerk agrees that that language
should be changed
from the bill shouldn't that be
incorporated into a new amendment
uh fine
good point
well
one of the aspects i'd like to address
as well is that
after this bill was heard i spoke with
the prime sponsor representative marsh
subsequent to that uh and he took my
point and i my understanding was that he
was
uh i asked him to think about a way of
doing something that might be very
appropriate it's not certainly not
beyond the i
anybody's imagination that a
commissioner could uh put forth some
kind of an order
that would be
just a bad idea something that shouldn't
go forward and there should be some way
that an expert committee of the of the
the legislature and that's what i spoke
to earlier uh could weigh in and say
uh
10 day hold 20 day hold whatever it
might be
some way of
putting the brakes on something that's a
bad idea
but i think rescinding is something that
we don't have the power to do as a
committee
so
i'd like to see us confer with
representative marsh to see what he may
have come up with in the meantime as
well but we certainly ought to check
with the clerk to see if this thing
flies or not
it looks like the clerk is
here for attendees
yes
that's interesting
that's just the computer at the head of
the desk
okay representative schmidt if you would
consult with representative varnish
again i will consult with the clerk
and if necessary get another amendment
so we'll
uh i think you're right we don't
this is beyond our authority at this
point
right thank you very much and i i
certainly will be happy to speak with
representative marsh again about what he
may have come up with
just
a couple seconds to say this i have
never ever liked the job car has to bow
to the
agency that's not finding the
legislature that's finding an agency
just never like the job card gets
overruled by an agency and
i did like day one i still don't like it
okay
fine
who cares
all right so
in that case moving right along
uh on house bill 417 i'm going to move
up to pass
and i move
amendment 0810
second
just a question have we been provided
with this amendment
yes sir it was sent out by miriam along
with the other amendments for today
okay
i have not seen it yet so i apologize
it's the one that i sent out of draft
earlier with the
uh technical issues like spelling and
fists
and
i will mention what it does it keeps
the
30 days
because that will eliminate the need for
renewal on almost all emergencies
and then it goes on
to say that the
executive orders need to be approved
and it adds in that the governor and
council
the governor cannot accept
emergency funds
by himself he needs to to have the
council with it
which is the normal
normal process
madam chair yes representative thank you
um i thought we were going to have a
work session on this we were i don't
know i don't think we discussed it we
discussed part of it but i didn't think
we were completed we had finished our
discussions
this is an executive session
if discussion is encouraged
and if it results in a decision
or a consensus to
revise the amendment then that will such
such will happen that's why i'm doing it
today
and not on wednesday i see thank you
representative roy
thank you madam chair um
i had emailed you my concerns
about the first section of this
amendment i just want to
reiterate those concerns that
the state of emergency
needs to be renewed by the majority of
each chamber of legislature prior
determination
there is no exemption in this as there
is in
the period that
follows in
the executive orders that says uh
if we are unable to meet that those will
automatically be
uh extended in a fourth day 14-day
increments that provision is not in this
first section regarding the
um
state of emergency and uh that's
concerning because if we are unable to
meet there's no way of extending this or
there's no circumstance to extend this
um so i want to bring that forward
you're right
that
if we can't meet it keeps the extensions
are approved
on 14-day increments you can just say
as as provided in paragraph whatever
oh yeah no it's
easy enough to fix but it it needs to be
delivered
[Music]
um and also i just
still have concerns about
the
if it's an extended state of emergency
that
fiscal committee is not included in this
i understand the governor and council
for a the brevity of an event where they
need to make quick decisions but an
extended
circumstance or emergency like we have
now i think and we heard
representative weiler even confirmed
that they should be involved yes and the
statutes defining the duties of the
fiscal committee specifically says that
any transfer over 100 that is
that goes through the governor and
council which these would has also has
to go through fiscal if it's over a
hundred thousand dollars
so they are involved
but not during the immediate
um
acceptance of a grant or whatever
because that is in fact time frame
is the governor able to suspend that is
that going to be
hopefully in our wording
we write a committee report
that uh that is the intent of this
legislation i hope yes
and
answer my own question oh excellent i
love that that's good when that happens
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so i'll come back
to a point that i believe i spoke to uh
when
uh when we discussed this previously and
that is that i this this is in my view
entirely driven by the extraordinary
circumstances that we can currently
confront with regard to a pandemic
ordinarily a governor's emergency orders
are going to apply to something which is
very temporary very reason very regional
i spoke about the alstead flood
which ripped out a highway
made this the community almost
completely inaccessible
and you know governor then governor
lynch
called the legislature in for a special
session
uh we
appropriated some money i believe to
take immediate action
but that was very local very temporary
and
hurricanes
floods
snow
most of these things are either regional
or
temporary or both uh whereas a pandemic
is a health
situation uh it's a it currently a one
in a hundred year situation uh and
representative pearson in his remarks
talked about the possibility
of an emergency at seabrook now that
would be of a different nature but it
certainly would be one that impacts
health
and
the last week was the 10th anniversary
of the fukushima disaster which
rendered that entire prefecture which is
basically like the entire sea coast and
southeast
uh corner of new hampshire
uh
uninhabitable
and
except for a few people who have come
back in against the government's orders
that entire area is now a wasteland
uh
and the idea that that the governor is
going to issue an executive order and
it's going to have to be renewed every
uh every couple of weeks effectively uh
is
that that's not really workable in an
extraordinary circumstance like we have
now i understand that
yes i would like to
explain that if you have a
an emergency of 30 days or less
which most of the weather related
emergencies are this does not affect
anything right this only affects renewed
states of emergency
and in the of something like
the like a secret disaster
we could meet
to consider executive orders at that
point it it's not if there's a regular
normal weather related emergency
it's we
actually extended it from 21 to 30 days
to make sure it won't need to be renewed
and the legislature will not have to get
involved because we don't need to
well i i do understand i'm aware of that
i do understand i think that this is
just
as i say it's an extraordinary
circumstance where it's believed by
people across the
spectrum i think not just not just
republicans and not just democrats uh
that the governor
it's it's that's of sense that many
people have that the governor has
exceeded his authority that he has
violated the law you know overstepped
the constitution and so forth and so on
and there's legitimacy to
you know uh to reflecting on that
uh
and i don't mean to dismiss it i think
that
we already talked about the joint fiscal
in my opinion should have been involved
in the expenditure of funds that this
gopher
task force that the governor created
that was completely his creature but
also completely under his control had no
authority over him whatsoever
was
basically like a hand puppet you know
disagreeing with the uh with the uh with
the of the with the owner of the hand uh
that's
you know
it's troubling
and it is something that needs to be
considered
uh
but i think that the idea that you're
going to get the legislature even if you
call it in
every 30 days and so forth
is i don't really think it's workable
and and ordinarily i don't think it's
it's a situation which would exist i
think the ordinary kind of natural
disaster type of emergency that we are
all familiar with we've had hurricanes
we've had floods and so forth that have
devastated certain areas for certain
periods of time uh
nobody's going to
object to the governor
getting everybody necessary involved in
that
uh in this current situation or the
seabrook emergency if it were to a god
forbid ever occur
uh those are
special situations
uh and i do think we need to look at
this that's why i think this bill should
be retained
so that we can actually sit down and and
strategize on
the appropriate way to make sure that
the governor cannot run wild
i don't think he's done that in this
particular case some aspects of the
lockdowns for example i thought the
initial cut before he said
essential please let me finish the the
essential stuff had
was allowed to stay open non-essential
had to shut down
i thought within relatively short order
that you could have said can this can
this business even though it's not
essential can it operate in a way that's
safe for its employees and safe for the
general public and if that's the case
that that business should have been
allowed to reopen so that the business
would not have been financially ruined
yes thank you
schmidt i agree with you completely on
that point
but
this
this bill is intended to be
a
rough night
to be a first pass in establishing some
control over emergencies we have
two other bills about emergencies that i
that i expect we will retain
and work on to develop these things but
i think that getting something out this
year
is
important to a large number of people to
make sure that the
that in a future emergency the governor
doesn't go off with by himself without
fiscal without
the legislature without anybody
and so this is a
relatively simple bill
well we recognize we've and this has
been discussed previously
that nothing's going to be done to stop
the governor this time around and and he
would be likely to veto it i don't think
there's enough agreement to override a
veto but that's hypothetical uh i i
understand where you're coming from i i
really have a serious question about uh
viability workability and and and that's
necessity
so
we'll
[Music]
put you on
yes representative
thank you madam chair um
i believe i'm of the understanding that
you are looking at uh crafting a
new amendment to this bill
and i would urge you i believe
a large number of members of the
committee would be
more comfortable with a new amendment if
it did at least include a
cross-reference
to the fiscal committee statute
all right i can see your point
representative blackness
um thank you ma'am chair um
so i i understand that in this uh you
know current emergency
there was general agreement um
you know not to end the state of
emergency and we haven't i think one of
the virtues of this
is that it permits the legislature
to review in you know individual
executive orders i think there were
there may have been executive individual
executive orders that
a majority of the legislature might want
to see either eliminated or at least
modified
and the problem is we only had this big
hammer which was either in the state of
emergency or not
and and that was a problem
so i think the biggest value of getting
this in is that to have a little more
fine-grained control the governor could
settle the state of emergency but the
legislature can review
um the individual orders and i think
getting that in is important
um i think you're right that you know
almost all the other kind of emergencies
except maybe a seabrook thing
uh this wouldn't apply and extending the
21 to 30 days kind of makes it more
likely that it wouldn't
but
i'm concerned that this sort of
emergency
may be more likely in the future than we
would have thought
you know we don't know what's going to
happen with you know new versions of
cove or some other disease or whatever
um so having a legislature involved both
in looking at the emergency orders and
having fiscal involved i think it's
important to get out there
as soon as we can and the effective date
of this isn't
until 30 days after the current state of
emergency is over so you know it's
it's not going to affect the current one
because we know politically that's
not going to work it may not be a good
idea for other reasons
i appreciate the thoughtfulness that
you're going at this with tony but but
again the workability to the degree that
you get the legislature in in something
that's not
obvious the pandemic
was not well understood and there was a
lot of
bad information that came out you know
from and so forth and people were
we were told by the then president we
were told this will go away this is a
hoax it's this that what have you a lot
of which turned out to be very bad
information but it misled a lot of
people now you're going to get the
legislation
representative allegro
i think it's such a simple building it's
interlocking and uh covers
several different aspects of an
emergency
i don't see at all where it's not
workable uh because the decisions are to
be made down the line
so it covers the immediate emergency by
giving the governor the
latitude he needs
and then it covers a more prolonged
emergency
if the legislature can't meet
and it covers a more more prolonged
emergency if the legislature can meet
and that includes a seedbook type uh
problem
uh but most importantly is that
it brings in the voice of the people
which is the legislature
and i think that's
the most important aspect of this so um
[Music]
i just i don't see
the complications or the non-workability
of it and
i like it with the minor changes that
need to be made
represent
just uh
representative lectus is referred to the
hammer and that's our only choice
i have never forgotten that we have that
hammer the question i have is why
don't people talk to one another if the
governor were to uh
act in an irresponsible capricious way
there's a president of the senate and a
speaker of the house that go into his
office and say hey look cut it out we
have the votes to stop this
people should talk to one another
including the governor talking to
committees about some of these bills but
that's
that's all i wanted to say
representative
i would just add that
currently the legislature has the
ability to stop a state of emergency
what's happened in the meantime is the
state of emergency has gotten too big to
fail so if we were to go in and pull the
drain plug on this right now it would
cause chaos throughout the state because
of the number of executive orders that
have intertwined themselves into all
facets of life economically health-wise
so
you know in theory we could do it but
practically we can't
and you know to represent schmidt's
point that you know this is a once in a
decade lifetime whatever
that's why we have emergency laws for
emergencies and so even if it is a rare
emergency we've learned it can happen
and we should prepare for it so i i
agree with what's been said this
provides flexibility for the governor to
deal with immediate emergencies but it
avoids a situation where we have a one
uh one person
controlling the legislative actions the
executive actions in some cases even the
court actions by by closing them down
for the last year and that was never
envisioned and we should be prepared for
that to happen again so i think that we
need to move forward with this bill now
other
other comments
okay in that case we will recess for
lunch i will get another amendment that
includes
a press reference to fiscal and an
exemption
it for
extending the emergency if the
legislature cannot meet
the same way and
bring that back after lunch
okay thank you very much
can you meet us
sure what time will you be returning
after lunch
uh
one o'clock should we
okay appearing at 1 30 so right
one o'clock great thank you
thank you
welcome back
and representative marsh and
representative
schmidt
have an amendment actually i was
impressed
where do you see how clever it is then
you'll really be impressed
yes all right representative pearson
do you mind withdrawing your amendment
your motion proof on amendment 0629
hospital 187
sure
and representative goalie you're
withdrawing your second
i am
all right representative schmidt do you
have a motion
i
do madam chair i don't have actually
have uh the amendment number but i ask
that it be sent to the entire edna
community
so
uh
you
some of you all of you may have it um
it's an amendment with myself and
representative marsh as the sponsors i
think he's the prime sponsor but uh what
it does is it adopts the methodology
that i reference in my remarks this
morning about the gel car where this uh
this committee of the
uh
the um
that we were referencing that we're
trying to have the authority with us
four fifths vote to uh to basically uh
suspend uh the comm commissioner's
order
subject to the approval of the
legislature
subsequently but in the mean
time the commissioner's order would not
be implemented
and represented mcguire the chair
is familiar with it from the shell car
with a joint resolution
so that otherwise otherwise we like this
we we want this uh this bill to go
forward i'm totally supportive it's the
the other aspect of it was troubling
okay so that if the joint resolution is
introduced timely
the
uh
the emergency order is
stayed until the resolution is settled
if the resolution is not timely then
now if well i guess if you missed the
boat but
the the the committee ought to be able
to act pretty quickly if they if you got
a four-fifths agreement among the
committee members that the
commissioner's order is unwise or
unwarranted uh then
i think they would do it you and i have
seen what that's like on the jail car
when we have a situation where the rule
is improper
in whatever fashion unsupported
that
a joint resolution gets enacted and the
legislature ordinarily supports that
because the jail car in that case is the
technical committee that recommends it
uh
and
i have a huge question yes
representative pearson representative
schmidt i'm curious as to why all of my
changes in part three were not included
in your amendment
the only change in my amendment is uh to
my
understanding is that that this
that the two-thirds
uh uh
uh suspect rescission of a
commissioner's order
will be changed representative schmidt
the issue is that we had an amendment
that we were considering and you should
have amended the amendment
rather than creating a different new one
and this isn't an efficient moment and
this is not an official amendment so we
can't do too much
all right
[Music]
well can we suspend the whole operation
until we can fix the amendment so that
we can act on it uh
in a profit form
i believe we that is the appropriate
thing because
uh
we can't have amendments all right we
will
put it off in other words
yes we
if we can't get ols
to support
um
support us this afternoon he's planned
to stay here as long as necessary on
wednesday
okay
because yes these these fixes should be
incorporated
in time
i want to get it right yes
we have at least two days
so in the meantime i will move that we
retain house bill 275
which is
relative the governor's power to
initiate a state of emergency and
various emergency powers
and we can use this to
all sorts of things in it that we can
use to consider
what we're doing on two on 417 and
modify it
uh
you can incorporate all this good stuff
in
second 30 seconds your
motion to retain
is there any other discussion
well hearing none i'll just say that
that i i absolutely agree that it's
appropriate under these circumstances
for
the legislature and in this case the
edna committee to
review the executive powers
of the governor
um with regard to
potential for overreach or
um
overstaying the the length of the
executive of the emergency situation
um
because
i think
these are legitimate issues for the for
the people of the state of new hampshire
to uh to uh have an input on
and we're the designated angels here
any further
[Music]
all right see none
the motion is to retain house bill 275
when reading the clerk will call
representative roy
yes yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes
representative bailey yes
representative lonzarro
yes
representative sanchez fosso
somewhere
yes yes yes
okay uh representative goalie
yes
representative
representative judy
thank you representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz yes
oh is that right
i wonder why
representative
yes
thank you representative trump no
representative
yes
representative o'brien
yes i'm the chair yes
it is
that will be retained
and i believe the only other bill we can
vote on is house bill 433
limiting renewal of states of emergency
does someone have a motion
representative roy moved itl on house
bill 433 is there a second
a second
that was truman yep
yes
all right do you just speak to your
motion uh just briefly we we've got one
bill that we're going to work on towards
passage and we've got another retained
in our pocket to work on further um so
keeping another one is is certainly
redundant so
let's clear up
all right
excellently brief
all right any uh
any further discussion
all right seeing none the motion has
been expedient to legislate on house
bill 433
and the clerk can call the world
representative
yes yes representative pearson yes
representative jacob
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
[Music]
yes
representative sherry yes
representative judy
not here representative schmidt
yes representative schultz
yes representative fellows
yes
the front now
representative wrote it
represented
yes
okay
uh representative o'brien
yes
and the chair yes
does anyone object to consent
all right hearing none
we'll put that on consent
it rides early
all right that's
representatives roy and goalie if you
could get your
committee reports in
uh
by midday tomorrow
we'll make still be in the calendar
i will do that madam chair thank you
very much
and since
we need an amendment on
187 and on 417
we will
take a break until the hearing starts at
1 30.
would you put up a notice we're going to
mute the turn off the camera and mute
the room
sure
thank you
you're welcome
uh
that's okay
[Music]
bill from the senate
personally it only has three parts
it's uh
my dad i'd have fun with this one
and representative mcguire just so you
know
a gentleman named
rick james has
you know registered to testify during
this hearing and i believe he he must he
might be the rick n-h-s-s-e-t-a-f
that's that shows up on the attendees
yes he could be here on section three
right
all right it'd be 1 30 i'm opening the
hearing on senate bill 105
and i call on senator cavanaugh to
introduce it
hello thank you good afternoon everyone
good afternoon madam chair and committee
members thank you for taking my
testimony
i'm introducing
senate bill 105 and the first section is
i filed this legislation to make my 603
the 11th state song this song was
written by nicole knox murphy of candia
new hampshire
in 2016 and since then she has performed
at many venues across the state
including uh for governor sununu and i
believe nicole is here to take any
questions as well um but with that i
just wanted to introduce juice
introduce that part of the bill and
thank you all very much for everything
you're doing and um i can take any
questions if anyone hasn't
all right thank you very much are there
questions for senator cavanaugh
all right there aren't any
that i can see
thank you very much
all right miss murphy
can you hear me yes
i'm sorry took me a minute
yes hi um thank you madam chair and the
committee um if you have a few moments
um i'd like to tell you a little bit
about the journey of the my 603 song
excuse me um yourself first give us your
name and where you're from
sure my name is nicole knox murphy i'm
from candia new hampshire
and i live here with my family
um
so um i want to just kind of give you
the journey i did send out an email
hopefully you got a link for the youtube
video
so you would have an opportunity to kind
of see
the full picture of what my 603 is all
about
but uh this song i was inspired to write
the song back in 2015. i was just on the
back of a motorcycle ride going to the
franconia notch with my husband
and i just was looking around at the
beautiful um scenery and the lack of the
man on the mountain thinking um it would
be really nice to have a song that would
represent new hampshire and what it's
all about and the beautiful landscapes
that it has
so on the back of that motorcycle ride i
just started having all these thoughts
so when i got home
a week later i had the lyrics written
and then i set up the melody to go with
the song and then my 603 was born
in february of 2016 i took a trip to
nashville to record my second album with
jerry webb at his recording studio and
my second album was called music is in
my heart
and the my 603 song was the second track
on that album
the journey continued for my 603. the
fall of 2016 i reached out to jim moscow
he's west side video to create a music
video for the song
we released the music video onto youtube
october 29 2016.
um
shows great drone footage and landscapes
it was all what i was trying to depict
of what new hampshire was about
and what it means to me
and which i shared with you guys the
spring of 2017 music in my heart album
won 2017's new hampshire country music
award for cd of the year
june of 2017 i was invited to sing to my
603 to governor sununu and his council
at the state house it was such an honor
then the journey continued
spring of 2018 music and my heart album
won two national awards in pigeon forge
tennessee
um my it was most promising album of the
year in 2018 and also i won rising star
songwriter of the year for
music and my heart album
a little fun fact in 2017
i applied at the dmv
and i was able to get my 603 as my
license plate so i was kind of happy
with that
um spring in 2019 by pure luck i was
singing at a celebration at the sweeney
post
and on the patio when mayor joyce craig
showed up and i was able to sing my 603
to her life
mayor craig
said she loved the song she took one of
my cds and said she would go to work
helping me get the song recognized
a few weeks later she introduced me to
senator cavanaugh and start to start and
help me with the process thank you
senator cavanaugh mayor craig for
helping me start this process
it's been a very
cool learning experience learning your
process of going through
making
something a bill is pretty cool
and the journey continued so summer the
summer of august 2019 i was invited to
sing my 603
at the northeast delta stadium on the
field before fisher cats game that was
quite a bucket list event for me
i've seen my 603 on many local radio
stations and fairs throughout the state
to get
the song out there
so during this crazy time of the
pandemic i would like to thank senator
cavanaugh and well they they and donna
soucy also
um honored my song june 29 2020 as a new
hampshire state resolution
and that was quite an honor to bestow
upon my 603.
um and then in december of 2020 that's
when senator cavanaugh entered my 603 as
a bill to be voted on and go through the
process that it's going through today
um i just want you to know that i am
nicole knox murphy i'm a wife of 37
years
a mother of three grown children
a grandmother of five and a local
singer-songwriter
i am grateful and honored and appreciate
your vote to continue this process to
make my 603
to represent new hampshire as a state
song
thank you very much
murphy are there any questions
representative schultz
honestly i don't have a question i just
wanted to congratulate her
and thank you for your song and your
performance i think that
that's fantastic uh
and i will be supporting it that's it
thank you
representative phillips
um
thank you i would like to um echo what
representative schultz said it's it's i
listened to it it's a cute cute little
song
um my question though has to do with
copyright like is the song copyrighted
because if we're going to adopt
something as a state song i think it has
to be available for anyone to
to use it and play it wherever and
whenever they want
well it's a i'm sorry can you hear me
yes
um
it's when i um administer all songs now
when you record music
are mp3s more than albums or cds so when
you go through the process of putting
your music online
i go through a company called tunecore
and that's how i distribute my music and
they copyright it there as it's
distributed out so basically it's on all
the major download sites it's on amazon
it's on uh
itunes it's on spotify it's on all those
major download cite you just type in my
603 and you can go and download it
um so but it's free i mean i give you
know if i have to sign something giving
you guys permission to
to play it or have me come play it i
mean i'm giving you the song as a gift
because i think new hampshire needs this
and i and it's something positive
and
but i think that's something we could
look into i
not sure
i don't know if i answered your question
or not well well oh follow up
follow up please
yes did i answer your question correctly
um
you um since since i don't know nothing
about how that works i appreciate your
answer because obviously i didn't know
how it works but i i do think that's
important i have no idea how to go about
doing that
well yes it's already copyright i have
copyrights to it um through tunecore
but you're not charging for its use
they use well no if they want to go and
download a song off
you know they will
i'd i get pennies for it because it goes
through a process but on like spotify
you buy a membership and i get pennies
for you know if somebody streams one of
my songs to listen to any of my songs i
have three albums out there so it i'm
but um
i have
it's my song but i give you permission
to play it and use it
thank you
representative
thank you madam chair hello ms murphy
um
are you a member of ascap or some
similar songwriting
group
no um i signed up for that many many
years ago but i never renewed it um
because i went through tunecore it's a
it's what a lot of the newer artists are
doing to distribute the music because
back then before they had a lot of um
was albums and some cds now that we're
in the whole world of mp3s and
downloadable music tunecore was the way
to go
thank you follow-up manager
um if if you
let me rephrase this if
someone were to use any of your songs
to do a cover of them for commercial
purposes
then you would definitely get a fee is
that correct
well i think if um
i was hoping if somebody wanted to use
my song that i would have an opportunity
to maybe come sing it live for or
for a commercial or be a part of it
somehow or being either tagged as the
writer
i mean i think it's important to know if
they use the song to give the person who
wrote it credit
thank you
i still don't know if that answered your
question
representative roy
thank you madam chair um
hello miss uh murphy um actually um
you're one of my constituents um so i
want to thank you for contributing in
the way that you have to the state
um thank you i just wanted to as far as
the copyright thing goes the way my
understanding of it would go is that
it's kind of like francis scott keys you
know the national anthem anyone can sing
it anywhere anytime
correct and that would have to be the
same with this if it's a state song um
anyone could sing it anywhere anytime
and there'd be no
copyright infringement because
as you said you'd have to actually i
think give it to the state or at least
wave your copyrights to it
is that your understanding
yeah i i think so i mean that like with
any song anybody can take any song like
i do the same thing when i perform i'm
always singing somebody else's music i'm
a cover artist
so i cover a lot of miranda lambert
a lot of the new artists out there for
country music
so i sing my originals i'm also covering
other people's music so
um
and
the places that i sing this music in
they have to have um pay fees to the
state
or to those companies licensing
companies to have people sing live music
in their buildings
so it's it's very
complicated but
i'm giving permission for
my 603 and if i have to actually sign
something
to say that that's the case that i'm
giving you
the song and
obviously i would like to be noted as
the you know the writer and creator of
the song
um
other than that
i don't know
how else i would go about
we don't either representative like
yeah i have a similar concern i mean you
know it's a nice song and it's i'm glad
you created it but if i was going to
support it to become an official state
song i would have to be completely
assured
that there was absolutely no copyright
issue and that anybody
could perform it anywhere in
circumstances um
and i don't know if they're you know it
sounds like you don't know the way to do
that i don't either at this point well i
mean all i can say is
um
like you said the national anthem
anybody can sing it anywhere this my
song is no different
actually it's less different because
i'm not as famous as the person probably
wrote the national anthem you know i'm
just a singer-songwriter in candy in new
hampshire
um
the national anthem was written
200 years ago
yeah it's out of copyright
the situations are not at all similar
representative allegro
good afternoon i should say uh thank you
for taking my question
um
does the producer or distributor of your
uh album music have any financial
interest in this because
they would also have to wait rights for
this to become public domain as well
all right so tunecore
is just a
online site that you pay
them to distribute your music
they don't own
my music but they they once you
upload your music there and you say you
are the writer of this song then they
say okay you're the writer and then they
say if somebody else starts to take your
music and they'll say no that belongs to
so and so but that's just to protect
music as it goes up online
and on youtube
but other than that that's the only
place
that
i uploaded my music to
so other than that there's no hold on
the song except me
thank you okay thank you
are there any other questions for miss
murphy
seeing none
thank you for your testimony for your
song
does that mean welcome we should testify
uh laura in
anahara
me okay
can everyone hear me okay
yes
okay let me lower my hand um so i'm here
to testify on the portion of the bill
related to metastatic breast cancer oh
we haven't gotten there yet
okay
hold on
sure is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on part one
seeing none in that case we move on to
part two
so yeah yes
anahar
okay good afternoon my name is laura
nahara i'm a resident of durham new
hampshire can you all still hear me just
checking
okay
thank you all for letting me speak and
to senator perkins culka and her office
for their guidance and support
throughout this process
when most people think of breast cancer
they think of the color pink and there's
a false misconception that there's a
cure for breast cancer
the purpose of commemorating october
13th
as metastatic breast cancer awareness
day also referred to as nbc in the state
of new hampshire
is for the public to understand nbc is
not pink
it is a stage four incurable illness
with a median life expectancy of only
two to three years this disease doesn't
discriminate it impacts all regardless
of age 115 lives are lost daily to nbc
in the us alone
i founded a campaign called light up mbc
that originated in new hampshire four
years ago
by lighting the memorial bridge in
portsmouth new hampshire and the mbc
awareness ribbon colors of green pink
and teal
the mbc awareness ribbon incorporates
the color of green
and teal in addition to pink green
represents triumph life over death and
teal symbolizes healing and spirituality
that then pink ribbon represents the
cancer originated in the breast
the goal of the campaign is to literally
shine a light on the disease and the
lack of funding it receives the campaign
has grown significantly since inception
last year on october 13th
every state in the us participated as
well as four international locations by
lighting a total of 160 landmarks in the
nbc awareness ribbon callers
october 13th is recognized at the
federal level as the official metastatic
breast cancer awareness day
other states have also joined in
recognizing october 13th at the state
level
with language inclusive of new hampshire
originated light up nbc campaign
by the state of new hampshire
recognizing october 13th as metastatic
breast cancer awareness day it will help
bring awareness to the public that 98
percent of all breast cancer related
deaths are from metastatic breast cancer
yet less than 5 percent of breast cancer
related funds raised go toward
researching treatments for mbc
the nbc community lives depend on
research
i know the impact of this disease all
too well it took my best friend's life
also a resident of new hampshire at only
36 years old
since her passing i've met many more
families impacted this disease by this
disease within new hampshire and across
the globe
we really appreciate your support of
this bill thank you for listening thank
you are there questions
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair and thank you miss
inahara
i have a question i was quite surprised
several years ago to learn that men can
also have
breast cancer
do
is that also metastatic or is it
differentiated as as it may be with
women i'm sorry not too knowledgeable
about the subject oh um yeah so men can
also you're correct they can also have
breast cancer i've actually met a man
with metastatic breast cancer
he was actually in our campaign last
year
speaking about his experience because
not many people are aware that men
can actually get breast cancer and any
person can get diagnosed at any stage of
cancer so you can be diagnosed at stage
zero one two three or four when you get
to stage four that is when it becomes
metastatic because it's spread
outside of the breast and into vital
organs like long liver brains bones and
it's metastasized so people sometimes
have the misconception that
you know there's a breast cancer
originated but then it came back as
liver cancer it's not actually true the
cancer spreads and actually attacks
different areas of the body
so you're actually actually correct men
do have this and i have met someone that
does
yeah i learned it from a friend it seems
it seems like there's a lot of
unawareness
uh
inspiration about the subject in general
even though it's
it's well known so thank you very much
for bringing it to our attention you're
correct and that's exactly what we're
trying this campaign is geared to do i
was one of those people that really had
two grandmothers that had breast cancer
and they were known as survivors i had
the misconception that if you get breast
cancer this is one of the better cancers
to have because you can overcome it
because i saw both my grandmothers and
so i got a hard reality when my best
friend was diagnosed and together we did
a lot of research and i learned a lot
more than i ever realized
attached to breast cancer
thank you very much you're welcome thank
you for the question
thank you madam chair
um my question is do you have
any events or
planned any events planned
on this day to try to get out your your
information because we can we can
identify something as a
as a
right day that's recognized in the state
of new hampshire but the state can't
really
do the information campaign for you so
i'm just wondering
i understand thank you yes we do um so i
actually um have a entire group um of
mostly women and men to the other
representatives point that have
stage four metastatic breast cancer and
we have we've created a community where
there's a representative across each
state
representing their own state so i help
with
new hampshire so um i work with the
local like i've worked with seacoast
online the past couple of years and
fosters to basically share why is the
because your point if you don't
understand why things are lighting it
doesn't really make a difference so
we've shared
why
the bridge in new hampshire if we take
it local to our state is lighting and
the impact behind that
and
we have
invited the community to the bridge
anyone whether you have stage 0 or stage
4 breast cancer to come and recognize
you know loved ones lost people have
brought their own luminary bag and we
make sure to clean up after we've never
left anything behind
but we also
collectively together with my fellow
light up mbc ambassadors we've sold
merchandise that says light up nbc
we raised over a hundred thousand
dollars this past year collectively
together
and all that money was dedicated to a
stage four metastatic breast cancer
research grant
um
out of we granted it there so it's
collective
um group effort not just beyond me
but yes thank you thank you
other questions
i see none i call uh senator quoca and i
apologize for not calling you sooner i
didn't see your name
senator
foreign
[Music]
yes senator probably you have been
recognized just unmute yourself and
speak
aha thank you i just didn't receive the
unmute button the first time my
apologies
good afternoon
uh for the record i am senator rebecca
perkins coca from senate district 21
representing the city of portsmouth and
the towns of mudbury lee durham new
newington new market in newfield the
prime sponsor part 2 of sb 105
recognizing october 13th as metastatic
breast cancer awareness day
this bill passed the senate edna
committee unanimously and passed the
senate on the consent calendar
the lsr creates a separate day to
specifically recognize metastatic breast
cancer metastatic breast cancer is among
the deadliest forms of breast cancer but
receives minimal funding research and
awareness compared to its effect by
recognizing october 13th as metastatic
breast cancer awareness day new
hampshire will highlight the disease and
call attention to its impacts as you
heard from mr inahara this is a very
grave disease that needs our support and
attention
madam chair thank you for the
opportunity to present and i'll be happy
to try to answer any additional
questions
thanks
are there any questions for the senator
i don't see any so thank you for your
testimony thank you madam chair
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on part two
on part three
[Music]
we have
rick means right
you would unmute yourself
yes that's correct rick
excuse me
before you speak senator hennessey
wishes to speak so i'd like that to get
her first
senator hennessy
[Music]
senator sees the prime of part three as
well
yes
yes you just unmute yourself from speed
there you go
thank you sorry i wasn't given an option
to unmute myself before uh thank you
madam chairwoman members of the
committee
my name is aaron hennessey i am the
senator for district one which covers
thornton all the way north through
pittsburgh and i'm here to introduce
part three which is a very exciting day
on april 8 2024.
there will be a full solar eclipse which
you can see
in the northern part of my district the
best part is that it's one of the first
places you can see it in the northern
hemisphere
and it'll be an exciting day for
students and
really anyone that wants to go out and
participate in this uh phenomenon we
have mr yeams with us today which will
give you more details but i am hoping
that you will pass this section to help
recognize it because like we saw in uh
former solar eclipses they are
they get a lot of people coming into
various states when when it happens and
there's a lot of demand on solar eclipse
eclipse goggles and there's also a bit
of planning that um i think our teachers
should be doing um in in order to help
their students participate in this event
so um i hope you will consider passage
of us and thank you very much
questions for the senator
seeing none
mr ames
thank you my name is rick keems and i'm
a resident of uh concord new hampshire
good afternoon madam chair maguire vice
chair roy and committee members i'm a 33
year resident and 30-year domino's pizza
franchisee here in concord
as a passionate solar eclipse chaser i
traveled to casper wyoming in august of
2017 to view what is truly a once or in
my case twice in a lifetime event
i had the good fortune to view and
experience at one hundred percent
the last tse total solar eclipse here in
the us
subsequently i discovered that the next
ustse on monday april 8th 2024 will be
100 percent over coast county and 95
plus percent over the entire state of
new hampshire for comparative purposes
the 2017
tsc with 65
over conquer
in the solar eclipse world 65 is a
lightning bug while 100
is lightning
two years ago i founded the new
hampshire solar eclipse task force
also known as the new hampshire ctaf
with fellow granite staters in the areas
of government and tourism
commerce education astronomy and
non-profits in order to network everyone
in new hampshire
to plan promote monetize and celebrate
this wondrous event
basically we have a celestial super bowl
coming to our backyard and we don't even
need to build a 200 million dollar
stadium to take advantage of it
however we do need to plan and prepare
as much as possible and as early as
possible to leverage our good fortune
for the entire state
after networking nationally with the
american astronomical society and nasa i
now know that there is no right time to
start getting ready for a tse
that leaves us with two options either
we will be early or way too late
i started networking the 2017 tsc about
a year and a half ahead and quickly
realized i was way too late
since after 2024 the next tse to occur
in new hampshire will be in 2079 i have
chosen to go nice and early with the n
the nhtse in 2024.
of course that's not even taking into
account a global pandemic potential
label blizzard or anything else that can
happen to us over the next three years
good thing we started early
last march our identical house bill 1382
sponsored by representative reid passed
the new hampshire house by a vote of 244
yay to 67 nay
thank you senator hennessey for
sponsoring senate bill 105
part 3 and for your past support as
representative hennessey of house bill
i'm here today to ask each of you to
vote otp on senate bill 105 part 3 so
that our entire state will have enough
time to plan prepare monetize and
celebrate this
fun spiritual and peaceful event for the
benefit of us all thank you madam chair
vice chair and committee members for
your time and consideration of our
request i'm happy to answer any
questions and or provide any additional
information that this committee may have
and or need
thank you
thank you representative scitec has a
question i'll
start your last name please
uh did you hear me mr uh uh neems is it
yeah mr yeems i did i didn't hear you
i'm sorry representative would you find
your last name please
thank you
yes do you have the long-range weather
forecast
i i do not but one thing that i've
learned is you can't control the weather
i've started to network with
a fellow
concord resident daniel fry
who
happens to be blind legally blind he's
done a lot of work with the
uh
national blindness foundation
and he is aware along with me of many
different uh devices that are used to
experience solar eclipses for visually
impaired folks such as sound vibration
and various other apps that are
available and our intention because
early april is not the best time
weather-wise in northern new hampshire
is to make sure far ahead of time that
we have plenty of these apps available
so that if weather does not
uh
help us out on that day we'll have
something for the tens of thousands of
people that'll be in northern new
hampshire to still experience this uh
once in a lifetime event
excellent thank you very much
representative pearson thank you and
thank you sir for uh
drawing attention to this i'm on um i'm
looking at national eclipse.com which is
a map a nasa map
basically
and just so just so i can get the
interpretation of this right
the the path that they're
that they're showing here which which
the center of never actually does travel
into new hampshire it's really close
but
the the rift of this path will be is
this
is this like the full the full monty if
you will the whole the whole shebang is
within the swath here
which seems to which seems to cross
intersects with 91 in vermont is that
is that the range of the full eclipse
that's that's correct the the eclipse
will start early in the morning
in miss atlanta mexico and then the the
zone of totality which is that zone
anywhere from 60 70 to 100 110 miles
wide the zone heads
from mazatlan mexico into texas
just goes just uh northwest of san
antonio continues on through i believe
10 or 11 states missouri arkansas
kentucky illinois
new york
ohio pennsylvania
and then heads into northern new england
goes through burlington vermont northern
new hampshire coast county
continues on through maine and then
continues through the maritimes
prince edward island new brunswick and
newfoundland so one of my goals in
starting so early because new hampshire
does not have great weather prospects in
early april
we are looking to be the first to have a
solar eclipse bill
uh not only in the us
but also in mexico
and canada so all of north america
and we've sort of tied in with the fact
that first in the nation primary we are
looking to be the first to actually pass
a solar eclipse day bill but uh i don't
think will be the last
however i i like i like to compare us to
uh neil armstrong when he stepped off
the eagle lander onto the surface of the
moon he did say that's one small step
for man this is one small step for new
hampshire but after that he didn't say
okay folks that's it we're good
everybody back in the lander we're out
of here we're heading home you know so
hopefully this might get a few other
states hopefully in in new england and
maybe other states across the country
will follow our lead
but uh i've learned that most people
remember who was first on the moon
second on the moon
even third in that group they never made
it to the moon they made it a lot closer
than i did but when you get up to 10 15
the the memory of of who walked on the
moon isn't as good so
i like to be number one or number two
and that's why i'm advancing this bill
working to advance it so early
thank you representative roy
thank you uh thank you for taking my
question i'm not sure if we answered or
not but what is um what would be the
if the river cooperates what would be
the best spot in new hampshire to be to
observe this eclipse
the best spot will be if you draw a line
from the southwest to northeast
from lancaster new hampshire
to milan
if you draw a line right along that
thing anywhere north
of that line
that'll be a hundred percent
totality that will be where it'll go
tonight in the middle of the day you'll
be able to see stars and planets this
actually the picture behind me my
background is a picture of the 2017
eclipse i did not take that that's a
picture from nasa that is actually at
sunset
as the sun is slipping beneath the waves
and it was eclipsed at that time and
it's just starting to see the diamond
ring effect the folks way up in
newfoundland and off the shore of
newfoundland will see something like
this on that day because they'll be
experiencing at it at sunset and
something else um that's coming up
really quick i haven't done anything
official with it but in less than three
months on thursday june 10th
here in new hampshire the east coast the
northeast i suggest getting up early on
that day because on that day at sunrise
at 506
the sun is actually going to come up
partially eclipsed by the moon
which is really really rare um there
hasn't been a lot of notice about it
because the main part of it starts north
of toronto goes over the north pole ends
up in russia but again we'll still be
able to see it and that brings up a good
point too even though the path of
totality is up in northern new hampshire
everyone in new hampshire will have
at least 95
and in salem nashua it'll be 95
and the farther you go north through the
state it'll go from 95 to 96 97 98 99
and then when you hit lancaster it'll be
totality and my
intention networking with tourism
commerce
local businesses
is to basically if you're not in
lancaster and north
to basically stage people south of there
in hotels bnbs wherever churches
wherever we can set up people and then
organize to people travel north north of
lancaster either the night before the
day of but obviously you can't set this
up a month or two or even a year ahead
this takes a lot of planning and that's
why we're advancing the bill so early
thank you thank you
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
uh
having had the privilege of seeing this
presentation the previous time
i i i
remember vividly that the
the
speakers
had some literature which i'm wondering
whether you have some for us or can
recommend linked to us
um because
to understand the significance of
early
planning
as you said in your opening remarks
a year ahead is too late
some of the
written materials were very impactful
and some of the people who talked about
the
eclipse their eclipse experience down in
tennessee i think
um it was very
impactful with regard to how important
early planning is
uh if because otherwise it turns into a
disaster do you have such a link or
i i do i sent out a package uh
representative roy i think you received
that package
i i had a response from you
i did yes okay if you could afford it to
uh representative schmidt and if there's
anyone else that didn't rece i thought i
sent it to everybody i may have it i may
have it i'll look for it
okay i get deluged
thank you very much
and thanks for providing the background
photograph that's pretty phenomenal
itself
representative fellows
thank you madam chair um my my question
is um
i remember
one of the things that i learned last
year when when we heard about your bill
was that you can't reuse those glasses
that we had
in 2017 so i think that's an important
safety
message
and is that
part of your uh planning to make sure
that there are plenty of glasses
available and that people know what they
can use and what they can't use
yes that's that's part of it and this is
something as i'm networking with nasa
and the aas across the country
representing new hampshire but linking
up with other states and other groups
one of the things that happened in 2017
is it was very tough to get the general
public aware
of what was happening and what was
coming down the pike and the resulting
that resulted in the
not large number of companies that can
make these certified
safe glasses because these glasses
safe to look at the sun that's all
they're good for you know you look at
the sun and you protect your eyes and
you can see the sun you can see the
eclipse but if you look at anything else
with these glasses you just see darkness
they're like a level 14 welder's glass
so it's very very important that we have
good safe glasses and that we have
people planning ahead people don't
plan to fail they just fail to plan and
what happened specifically in 2017
was as august 21st got really close
people realized they didn't have glasses
as we all do these days they went online
many of them went to amazon and amazon
did have glasses but some of the glasses
that amazon had were coming from china
and unfortunately the the safety the
copyright laws how they do business in
china is not quite the same as here and
i
have nothing for or against china or
amazon however some of the glasses that
were obtained by that route were not
proper glasses they were not
safe
and when you're talking about your eyes
and looking at the sun
you need to have that assurity far far
ahead i think amazon actually ended up
taking down stuff or not selling it now
everybody was confused and one of the
things that some people don't realize is
there are no
pain sensors in your eye
so when you're doing damage to your eye
by light you don't feel it you don't
realize it but if you're using improper
glasses or something that's not blocking
out the rays to protect your eyes you're
doing eye damage you don't know it you
might not know it even for a couple of
days and one of the things is eye damage
can often be
permanent and can often be irresistible
and given the fact that you only have
you know one set of eyes it's not
something you want to be messing around
with so my networks have
very experienced very safe people
another thing that we can do
if we plan early enough is we can enroll
optometrists and ophthalmologists
throughout the state and let them know
hey if someone has a question about a
pair of glasses are you willing to
be a site that they can bring the
glasses to you prior to the event and
make sure that they're good
and again there's so many different
things i mean
one thing that they planned in casper
wyoming when i was out there
all of a sudden six months before the
event people realized because it was in
august they didn't have enough
porta-potties
and they started calling around to get
more porta-potties and lo and behold
because the event was everywhere nobody
had any left and they have to source
them from quite a ways away at quite
significant expense so
it's the little things you want to look
at and
you know we have a super bowl coming but
it's not just a super bowl in our
backyard it's the backyard of maine new
hampshire quebec ontario
uh newfoundland new york so there's
going to be
we want to be early better to be early
than way too late
thank you thank you
representative
thank you madam chair um
hello mr james i'm curious
if you have a project projected time of
day
that the total eclipse would be
occurring in new hampshire
i do it's going to be approximately
3 30
p.m in the afternoon
the whole event however will start at
about 2 o'clock
and will run till about 5.
so it's a slow process as the sun starts
to i'm sorry the moon starts to move
across the sun and the picture behind me
shows
the end of totality and the moon is just
starting to move off of the sun it's
called the diamond ring effect that is
stage three
so pretty much prime time
yes prime time however
planning is is important you could be up
in pittsburgh you could get a hotel and
then you could realize gosh looking to
the east there's a big mountain there
and if
you know the mountain if the sun
uh goes behind the mountain at quarter
of three or three o'clock
that you're not going to be happy you
will not be pleased especially if you
were told
this is somewhere that has a room so
again
um i can't emphasize
how much planning can be done and
obviously we want to get the the b and
b's the airbnb the hotels everyone on
board one of the things that happens too
is prior to the event people come in
over the course of say a week
so you know there's people coming in
slowly
you're not stressing out the gas
stations the restaurants the area
attractions then the event happens what
typically happens is
five o'clock everyone goes okay that's
it do we have school tomorrow do we have
to work
we're out of here and it's akin to when
you land in an airplane and everyone
hops up and then stands there for 20
minutes for many people it took an hour
or two to get to the site of totality
and then it took anywhere from 12 to 24
hours to leave so we're going to be
encouraging people to stay an extra day
or two oh and while you're there why
don't you check out some of our
attractions and you're going to need to
eat and a place to stay for an extra day
or two but we'll give you a deal so
all this requires just a tremendous
amount of planning and i don't know if
laura it sounds like she's still
on the phone
one of the things that we're starting
ahead of time i think that was in the
package not only do we have our event on
monday april 8th 2024
but less than six months earlier on
saturday october 14th 2023 there's a
second eclipse coming to the u.s
that one's going to be out west
that's going to go
i'm sorry i i
i could talk about this for hours and
please anyone who wants more information
and i realize you're on a time schedule
i apologize yes thank you that's it
anyway uh does any any other questions
uh seeing none
there's a ms sally jensen who i believe
wishes to speak
i think he should be able to
you should be able to unmute yourself
miss jensen and speak to us
there okay can you hear me now yes
okay thank you thank you
madden
committee chairman and to all the um
members
i'm sally jensen i live in campton i'm a
retired teacher
still working in curriculum and still
presenting to different groups
and i'm very excited to be able to
support this
bill
totally i'm working with rick ames and
i can share with you an event that
happened in
may 10th
i was in my classroom with my fifth
grade and we had an annual eclipse that
went over plymouth new hampshire
and we had to stay indoors
and
look at a tv to enjoy that
so we need to be
prepared ahead of time
and work with educating teachers
and this is the most natural
stem event and we need to make it so
that students understand what's
happening and they're safe
and i'm presently working on
a book list four different book lists
for librarians and for different school
systems
and the first
book list will be for
young readers from zero age to ten
the next will be middle school and high
school and then adult reading
and i hope to get those ready and
distribute those to help people
understand and be educated and if you
think about it we need to have
families
students
communities understand our
earth moon system
if you think about our if we didn't have
the moon our life would be really
different we'd have shorter days
the weather would be wild
we'd have
no songs about the moon and there'd be
no honeymoons either
so i just want to let you know that
i'm totally in support of this and
i hope we can do this
thank you very much miss jensen
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 105.
representative foreign
sean fargan you should be able to unmute
and speak to us
okay thank you very much madam chair um
i just wanted to double back to uh
section one the my 603 song which uh i
think is an excellent song i uh
so i think it's a it's perfect as is and
it should become another honorary state
song there seems to be a lot of
questions about the copyright i mean i'm
a creative person myself i don't know
all the ins and outs of it's probably a
songwriter probably knows more than i
did but there just seemed a little bit
of confusion during the discussion so
the way
first of all we've many of our honorary
state songs maybe all of them are
already uh written by you know
by people who write songs for a living
like like mr murphy does including um
including two very famous singer
songwriters who recently passed away who
used to be like used to live in the same
community as me i'm not sure if they
were my constituents but uh the shaw
brothers who did a new hampshire
naturally so i don't
i don't think it's necessarily
i don't think it's necessary and it
seems a little unfair to make her uh
sign over the rights of the song and put
it to the public domain i think the way
it works um
we can just make it an honorary state
song and she could still continue to
collect small amount of royalties that
she gets when it's streamed or
somebody covers it on an alpha or never
because like the way public performance
works is
the venue is
if any was charged for it and then
the performing rights organizations
including a tune for it but you heard
about uh try to divvy
give it up which is kind of an exact
science but um so that's
how we should continue to do it i think
you should you may want to consult with
the house counsel you may also want to
look back uh
thank you representative
so yeah i think you
i i was i guess advice against uh asking
her to sign away the rights to the song
because i don't think that's necessary i
think she should continue to collect the
small amount of royalties that she's
getting from it so that's uh
representative morgan and you should go
back and look at the the laws that were
passed in 1983
when new hampshire naturally was and
then 2007 when a song called live free
or died by barry palmer
so thanks
miss murphy you wish to speak again
sorry um no i just was uh raising my
hand just in case um i needed to answer
a question um
so no i'm good unless to somebody who
has more questions for me
are there any
no i don't think so thank you
we grilled you pretty thoroughly the
first time
yeah i totally wasn't expecting all
those questions i guess i didn't really
think about all those things
um i just honestly just wrote a song for
new hampshire and i just wanted to share
it
and my love for new hampshire and um
appreciate your having done so thank you
very much
and what she did has been done before so
thanks
yeah thank you i guess i have a question
for you for the chair is is that
something that pam can do a quick flip i
don't know
all right is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on senate bill 105
all right see now i'm going to close the
public hearing okay here
and thank thank you all for being here
madam chair i have a question
oh
yes representative schultz thank you um
i think at our last exec session before
lunchtime
um
i believe
uh representative schmidt was muted is
that am i right that he was muted
i
i think he kind of ran out ran out
okay well
here's why i'm bringing it up of course
you know i was muted when i um
spoke during the executive session on hb
544 and i think i was muted
when questioning
um
folks which i understand i would just
like to say if he was muted he was um
making a point about trump's handling of
covid
um
and of course we could disagree on
things about trump and that's
understandable
but wouldn't it be better than muting
him
doing as you do when we're all in the
room together
which is um i don't remember if you
exactly gavel or not but you do a good
job actually of explaining why
um we veer off
or whatever reason that you call us out
of order
and then you give us a chance to finish
what we were saying senator schultz
this is why
i muted him he was getting seriously off
track
i tried to gather him i tried to tell
him to focus on the bill and he would
not do so i was unable to reach get
through him on this interface
so i muted him so that he would stop and
i was prepared to recognize him again to
for him to complete his thoughts if he
had not done so it's very difficult to
get through to somebody on zoom to tell
them you're getting way off track you're
not
talking about what we're here to talk
about
and
i know it is difficult because of the
separation
of those of us on zoom versus those of
us in the room
and i i
respect
how you handled this for sure you know
when we were all in person i wonder if
we can find
a new way to address this because i
don't even think representative schmidt
realized he was muted or i don't i
think i heard you
try to interrupt him i'm not so sure
that he heard you
and i you know i wonder if we can find
a fairer way to notify
those of us on zoom if we if you are
calling us out of order which is your
right
i don't know what that is
or what it should be but i'm just
suggesting
um maybe a different
approach
if you can come up with a way to get the
attention of someone who is in full
spate
and not paying attention to
other voices or gavels or things like
that i would love to hear what your
suggestion
and i will implement it but until then
the only thing i can do is to someone
who is
speaking at length on something that's
off topic
is to mute them and say and then go back
to them and say we shut you off and and
ask if anybody needs to speak because
we could spend all day list going off
topic and
on many occasions we've we've come close
[Music]
that's fair i wonder if um while it
might be annoying for the folks in the
room with you
if maybe gaveling
a few times would be helpful
i don't know if that's the solution i'm
just suggesting it
yes thank you i've i tried gambling you
down just recently and you and you kept
right on going
so it's it's clearly ineffective for
people who are not physically in the
room and will have to come up with a
better way
if you think of one let me know i'd love
to hear it well hopefully we all get our
shots soon and can be in the same room
by mid april i'll be in the room
but um
you've been very fair in explaining the
reasons you know in the past we've been
gaveled out and i've appreciated that
about you and i hope we can find
a good approach to that that works for
everybody whatever that is i don't know
that we figured it out yet just making a
note of it
all right
so
do we want to exec senate bill 105 or do
you want to get information on this
copyright stuff
yes okay i've had at least one vote for
getting information on the copyright no
no
what exactly oh
sorry well at least one vote for exec
i would be interested in having you move
your amendment
i'm sorry mr
i would be interested in having you move
on your amendment
i have two amendments
but um
okay
okay it sounds like there is a uh
interest
representative schmidt
i'm here restlessly awaiting your
decision
waiting what
[Music]
oh what
it sounds like there is at least some
interest in
uh proceeding to exec
so we will do so rep representative roy
do you have a motion
second
i'm sorry are we voting on a pass on the
uh
representative roy very quietly and
politely moved on to pass
second
and this is what bill on the bill itself
bill 105 which we have just heard
is there a second
second
from representative schultz
do you wish to speak to your motion
representative roy i do um
so i think
it's a rather um
easy bill uh the state's law enforcement
i really appreciate the work that this
citizen put into it i think that should
be encouraged
it doesn't cost the state anything we
have other state songs and this will
just add to that and i think it's a it's
a good it's a good example of
civic involvement
where you apply your skills that are
best suited to you
with regard to the um
metastatic breast cancer i think there
could never be too much awareness for
that and again this is just an awareness
day it doesn't cost anything it's an
official holiday or anything of that
nature
um so in the eclipse i mean just how
cool is that so i'm going to go ahead
and move out the past
all right you did representative schultz
do you want to speak to yourself
yes isn't it fun when representative roy
and i agree and we agree
um we have already passed section three
before i realize not everybody
uh was on this committee at that time
but we in the house did pass that before
and
um i happen to know uh rick eames and
his
enthusiasm is infectious
i think uh
that both of the other two sections are
um very good it is my understanding
that
and i will say my knowledge of this is
limited
but
my understanding of the way copyright
law works is
if you have representation and lawyers
who push
that sort of thing then it
might be enforced to some degree but
she's already given us permission in her
testimony for anyone to use her song
with that with her permission i think
that is actually all you need
i'm not a lawyer uh but having worked at
churches where copyright is
actually making sure your chorale and
your uh
sunday services are properly uh copy
written
uh that process is taken very seriously
and i think you literally only need the
permission of the songwriter i might be
wrong on that but i'm fairly certain
that's the case
um
i think all three sections are um
great and i hope that we can agree on
this on the bus bill thank you great
representative schuett you have a
comment
thank you madam chair
actually i guess
a comment and a question
question of the chair first
um
if we just do ought to pass then you are
not going to bring your amendments on
this bill is that correct
i'm
yes uh that is the motion if
while we're discussing it i might move
either of them
the point is that i
personally fully support
solar eclipse day i don't really
care about the saints song and i
kind of think
another cancer awareness day seems
redundant because it's
it's more effective if the
the cancer group
each year petitions the governor because
it keeps them involved we've opposed
special days for that reason
but
i'm not opposed enough to fight the
entire committee
thank you um
follow-up
yes just a suggestion to um
representative roy if if this motion
prevails
uh to be sure and
state in the blurb which will establish
legislative intent ms murphy's remarks
that she does
give unequivocal permission
for the use of the song
representative
thank you
the issue about the song hasn't been
resolved i will not be voting for this
um
bill
i would rather support what your
amendment that just includes the number
three the solar eclipse day that's the
only thing that i'm interested in at the
time
i just wanted to let you know
thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i too will be
voting against this motion hoping that
uh your amendment will be brought
forward for just uh
solar eclipse day um
i
told the members of this committee
before my stance is on continuing to
name days as we get
five or six of those bills every year
and it's just
overwhelming as we go on and i think it
dilutes the purpose
um for that reason i won't support this
motion and hopefully
uh support your amendment coming forward
thank you
thank you representative fontenot
uh thank you madam chair and it's a
question i guess and maybe i should have
asked it earlier but um
clarification
i was concerned about the song when i
was thinking it was being named the
state song
but apparently
it's just a
state song uh to be shared with numerous
others i i guess i don't know what the
difference is and maybe somebody on the
committee can
other songs that are labeled as
as state songs at the moment
so
it's a lot of rare it's an honorary
title
so i would have no opposition to it in
that
in that case
representative
um allegra you uh i would uh i could
address the whole bill
a little bit later uh as we move on but
i want to address a couple of the
elements of it
i was just about to say we already have
a states on and there are i guess
somewhere between eight and ten
that receive honorable mention
our current state zone which is old new
hampshire actually
talks about lakes fields forest rivers
rails and so again it touches on the
natural aspects of new hampshire
there's another aspect which
makes it a little bit more difficult for
me yet what happens
when area codes are no longer in use or
when new hampshire splits into two area
codes which is inevitable
and then
well i'll just uh
i'll leave it at that for that bill
breast cancer awareness we just have
in spite of what some people might
suggest we have tremendous
uh efforts going on around the country
in the state for breast cancer awareness
and then also often the other comments
for a little bit later if the
conversation about the girl proceeds
um i agree with the others who uh
support part three i see the solar
eclipse day more as a economic
development thing than anything else
and uh
you know i agree that
i mean there are many
diseases cancers that are fatal
and all of them could use additional
attention and
there's a power to tremendous publicity
about breast cancer i mean maybe they
could work in that community to get a
particular the metastatic thing
recognized more
think we have some concerns with the
copyright issue in the state so
so i'd prefer the amendment that
governor wanted to all right
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair i i have some
reservations with regard
the song aspect um
although she seemed quite open to
letting us use it and so forth she
seemed quite uncertain about several
aspects of it uh and i i think we would
be
remiss in our responsibility if we
didn't check with uh
uh
with the
house attorney or someone to see what
the law is
because it's
as harmless as as it might seem to the
degree with that we jump in on something
where we
inadvertently goof it up
just for lack of a little bit of
foresight
uh would be a shame because i haven't
had a chance to hear this song i agree
with representative allegra that that uh
my 603 i thought right off the bat we
all almost split up already and i think
it's inevitable that we will um and
so
there's there are a couple of aspects
there uh so i think that um
i'm certainly in favor of alerting the
public
and the uh the
the economy
aspect of it is of the solar eclipse is
going to be enormous
um
we're going to have thousands of people
who are going to regret if they got into
it too late just for lack of information
so we should absolutely pass that the
other stuff i've spoken to thank you
representative
thank you madam chair this is um
i guess in the guise of a parliamentary
inquiry
if ought to pass fails
then the bill would not be subject to
amendment am i correct
representative i would as soon as the
last person which was yourself had
spoken i was about to move the amendment
okay thank you
all right
seeing only people who have spoken
before
i i move amendment 0901
h
which deletes sections 1 and 2.
is there a second oh second
all right
uh
well we have roy and schultz already
they have brought to pass
and um
i prepared this because just looking at
the bill
i'm as representative goalie is i'm
concerned about announcing
special days when we already have so
many of them
i
remember the time when we had a hearing
on a special day that happened to occur
on congenital heart disease day
which is
february 14th by the way and nobody in
the committee or the sponsors of the
bill knew that that was a special day so
i'm convinced that
asking the governor to announce a
special day is more useful
than uh
than putting it into statute can be
quietly forgotten
and the song
breaks on lovely we've got 10 already
i'm not sure
of the need so
i'm moving this amendment
from sound blackout
okay uh
discussion representative schmidt
thank you madam chair well the thing is
i i
i don't want to make a final judge
i don't know the lyrics i don't know the
melody uh and
and i i would hate to dismiss the offer
out of hand
until i've heard it until what we've
checked and and checked on the
the copyright aspect of it uh so
um
that that i think because the amendment
kind of
dismisses the song
in its
application as as the bill suggests
so i won't vote for the amendment but uh
i think we're going at it
um
i think we're going at it wrong
senator roy
thank you
um
i think that
with regard to the song
we have a citizen in new hampshire who
dedicated some time and energy
is willing to donate a song that that's
[Music]
to be used as one of our songs the
governor's already shown an interest in
it
[Music]
and i think that this type of creativity
should be encouraged by the legislature
[Music]
furthermore
it does not hurt to feature
our
our artistic
[Music]
citizens it's just it's another good
thing to show that new hampshire you
know produces we have artists we have
painters we have songwriters so there's
nothing wrong with featuring one it
doesn't hurt anybody to add it to the
list of songs however many they may be
it's comes down to just a matter of
principle either being for or against
and i think that when we're talking
about one of our fellow citizens it
doesn't hurt to be four
with regard to the breast cancer
awareness day again this is i i am
totally on board with we should not be
having all a list of holidays
but as far as days where we
call awareness to something
again
there's only upside to to this
particular one we're talking about a
horrific disease
and to be able to just bring attention
to it one day i don't again there's no
cost
there's no infringement on rights i
don't see how it
that does anything negative so
i'll be voting against that amendment
anyone else representative pearson thank
you very much i believe the
kirkwood family i believe in the
testimony that was given in reference to
october 13th as metastatic breast cancer
awareness day the the person who
presented indicated that that was
already recognized in federal law as the
day so
i just don't see the necessary
redundancy there
and i i would agree with representative
goalie on on his points when it comes to
uh
the plethora of days that we are asked
to to
put into a dusty lava
thank you
[Music]
not hearing too
much there yeah you'll have to get
closer to a uh
200 foundation
pull that one over
so i'm voting against the bill
right
that's before
representative brodar
[Music]
i'm you jackie
thank you i support this amendment
although the other issues are important
um i don't believe that we need another
song
i also um
don't believe that um help having
metastatic cancer day is going to do
anything
to the organization i think that
you know if we want to um address these
issues there are many issues many health
issues i think we need to address them
in a more significant way
so i still think that the solar eclipse
day
does bring revenue to the state so i'll
be voting for the amendment and i thank
you for submitting it
thank you representative schultz
um
i i i'm not quite sure how to say this
but i just want to point out
that
these this this
more staunch stand on being against
naming days i hear your reasons
but unless you ban them from being
introduced
they'll keep coming up
and i don't want to ban that
um it takes as much time to vote for it
as it does to vote against it
so
if they've taken the time to file the
bill because one of their constituents
or people that they work with on these
issues
are asking for this to be recognized by
the legislature
and it costs nothing and it's not
harmful all the other things you say
about it are also true
with the you know there's a federal
recognition too that's not a problem i
mean there's no harm in doing it
whatsoever
none and it's a positive
thing to provide
the average citizen who otherwise may
not be engaged in civic uh in the civic
arena and anything else
um
i just find this
it feels kind of new to me the way that
there's this
sort of
um stand to just be against all of them
and i think it's a
i would like to see a more positive
attitude
um towards civic engagement just
to dismiss that i believe is is the
wrong
um approach
thank you representative
thank you madam chair um
i will be supporting the amendment i
tend to agree
that i'm not in favor of putting a lot
more things into statute
particularly the breast cancer
item
i'm very sympathetic to that cause
relate to the american cancer society
every year
my mother passed away from
pancreatic cancer so i'm very
sympathetic to that cause but i do know
that the american cancer society itself
fights for all different
aspects of cancer and as representative
pearson
pointed out there is
[Music]
oh thank you
as representative pearson pointed out
there is
a national recognition day
and i'm sure the governor will support
recognizing that without having to put
that in statute
and i definitely
agree with
supporting the eclipse day
and that does not go into statute
so thank you
representative phillips
thank you madam chair um i'm 110
in favor of this amendment
for the same reasons that i supported
the solar eclipse bill last time we
heard it it's great for tourism and it's
also a
educational opportunity because it'll be
during the day i mean kids can
well maybe they'll be on their way home
but kids kids can learn about this
i have concerns about the song the
copyright's one issue the other issue is
as representative allegro said you know
maybe we won't always be this just this
zip code and if if
i'm also concerned about the fact that
promoting somebody's
song
could generate revenues for them
and that if we go start to go down that
road we will have more
people asking us to
adopt their songs
so that's all i have to say thank you
representative
uh
when's constitution day
i didn't hear you it's in september
uh representative schultz one of there
is a downside and that's that we become
anesthetized
to these things here's what we do with
state reps
with respect to breast cancer
salem dairy has a relay for life
sponsored by the cancer society i've
been going every year they've had it as
state reps who are people in the
community we should talk it up with our
local papers and just talk it up show up
be there at the relay for life you want
to do something that's real that that's
my vote
and
the rest i'm not in favor of really any
of this because by the way stakes on
don't play it if you're not worried
about copyright uh solar eclipse it's a
great idea but that's what the chamber
of commerce is about you're not the
chamber of commerce and i just don't
want the additional
clutter
uh
so well it's not harmful it's not
helpful either i'm done
simple
representative thank you for recognizing
me representative scitec stole my line
which was a central issue for me
i look on my shoulder and there's a
shelf with just thousands and thousands
of rsas
and i think that the solar eclipse thing
is a tremendous business development
opportunity but it should be handled by
the chamber of commerce and other
business development agencies in the
state
so um
i'm not strongly in favor of the
amendment at all
i want to say i also agree with
representative cellos during the
testimony
on state song
i couldn't help but be concerned that
this is really a
an opportunity for the songwriter as
much as it was anything else um
[Music]
and that that was just my opinion
so um
i just we have so many laws and
and
[Music]
i'm going to enjoy and
be present and
[Music]
doing things on solar eclipse day no
doubt
but i just don't think we need yet
another
law in this area
thank you
that's actually not a new statute it's a
session one i'm sorry
that's not a new statute it's just
session one
it disappears it disappears yes
representative
thank you madam chair and i'll be brief
um
establishing a state song as
uh six of my 603 as a state song
like we said there's already a number of
them on the books and i don't think uh
at least i don't believe anyone
on this could state all of them that are
listed currently
[Music]
and as of naming october 13th i i think
we already recognize
the month of october as breast cancer
awareness month i think we've all worn
either a pink ribbon or something pink
during the month
a whole month of october and to add
another day
specifically for a specific
breast cancer i think
those individuals
have that ability during that month
to get their point across as to the
different kinds of breast cancer that
are out there
um without having to have a specific day
during the month
for that reason i'll support your
amendment and uh that's all i have to
say thank you
representative pearson
thank you
uh i'm going to support the amendment i
think there's one more element to
solar eclipse state beyond just an
economic drive and that is a
an educational
um driver then in the schools i i happen
to be
yeah this would be shocking i happen to
be a senior in high school the last time
this happened in 1994 and uh recall all
of the things that occurred at pinkerton
academy um in reference to that day and
what we did so i
you know i don't want the the
educational aspect of this lost lost in
the discussion as well so i'll be
supporting
representative schultz
um i just feel like first of all i have
a question uh did i see correctly that
this omnibus legislation passed the
senate 23 to one
that's very likely yes
i did and i i get that we can you know
kill anything the senate gives us
and
you know there's a reason why these
senators
brought this to us
um
having a hard time expressing my
frustration other than to say
the fact that they took the time to file
a bill have a hearing pass it with the
chamber and almost unanimously
i feel like
if we shoot down this omnibus
legislation and only pass one section of
it which i support that section of
course i feel like it's just a bunch of
negativity we it's the wrong kind of
bipartisanship i'll leave it at that
thank you
uh representative scitec
i just wanted to mention to
representative goalie that the color
that the american cancer society is
interested in is not
pink it's green
and every
september they come around and ask the
teachers
you get it
okay any anyone else
i'm sure i was just wondering if i could
call the question if that was an order
no you can't
it cannot be called in committee
okay
yeah discussion seems to have died down
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
representable
i just want to say i stand corrected on
my thinking in a in favor of this
amendment
all right thank you
all right the
anyone else
okay the motion on the on the floor is
to amend
senate bill 105 with amendment 0901
h
delete section one and two
essentially
uh
what happened to the ought to pass by
roy and schultz you know
you have to vote on the amendment first
before you can vote on the pass
as well
i think that's
i i know you have to say
want ought to pass and then is open for
amendment and then you vote on the event
for amendments as the case
all right if there's
no further discussion
representative roy no
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes
representative
representative bailey
yes
representative ronzara
no
passover
yes representative judy
representative schmidt
no
representative schultz
representative fellows
yes
representative
[Music]
yes
representative
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair
something to five
to four five fourteen four there are
five people
what was your vote please
yeah i voted now for that amendment
sorry i hear you
okay
and schmidt insurance
yeah
i said i maybe
[Music]
all right the amendment has been adopted
adam chair um i will state that there
was
some sort of interference during the
voting
i could not hear representative allegro
or bailey
they're both here
thank you i'm just pointing out that
there was some kind of interference
during that vote
thank you for that information
probably a stolen flare
[Music]
all right and i will move what to pass
with amendment
is there a second
oh well
representative
well
yes
since they both voted against the
amendment i can't expect either of them
just
to move on to password mcgregor and who
is the second person
don't think anything needs to be said
by me or john pearson
in okay case when ready the clerk can
call the role
senate bill 105 with amendment 0901
h which the committee has just adopted
uh on that now the motion is uh that's
the motion representative right now
the clerk votes no representative
peterson
yes
representative
representatives yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lanzara
yes
representative
now
yes
representative judy
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz
no
representative fellows
yes
representative
[Music]
yes
representative broda
yes representative o'brien
yes
and the chair yes
14 4
all right i will
write a report does anyone wish to write
a minority report
i think it will not go on the consent
calendar please just a clarification
okay representative roy will be writing
a minority report
good luck on that one representative roy
will be writing a minority report
no i just wished him lucky
we have
always i know our reports are always fun
and excuse me madam chairman may i just
interject i just um emailed to everybody
on the committee a revised amendment
house bill 187
that incorporates
representative marsha's proposal
with
representative pearsons
thank you very much
you're welcome
in that case perhaps we can go on to
send house bill 187
i don't think we got any of that
representatives
of not having voted the ought to pass
before voting on the
amendment but we never vote on what to
pass before the event
yes the parliamentary procedure is that
someone has to has to
essentially move ought to pass and then
move the amendment
normally it's not a full motion on the
ought to pass
because
the amendment is part of it in this case
the amendment came out because the
uh
because the discussion on the bill
revealed that there are many people
concerned about it and therefore an
amendment was
legitimate perhaps we should should have
voted on the ought to pass before we
took up the amendment
i'm not objecting it's just that i have
to write another piece of paper that's
all
i'm terribly sorry
[Music]
ma'am cheer um may i move her amendment
for house bill 187 or to somebody who
wants to submit the amendment
move it
now
she can move it also representative
pearson has
gladly seconded your motion okay what
was the amendment number the oh nine
five two eight
again it's zero nine five two h
i'm sorry i'll get closer to my
microphone is this better yes
thank you
okay so
yes representation you did withdraw your
previous motion
yes yes yeah that was a job
okay
makes it better
so representative product
moves amendment
[Music]
seconded by representative pearson
is there any discussion on this
amendment
i can say that um excuse me i can say
that um this amendment clarifies the um
earlier amendment
involving the house of representatives
and the senate with on the committee
and that that is addressed in paragraph
eight on page one of the amendment
so i think this amendment addresses the
concerns that the committee had
with the original house bill 187 excuse
me of uh representative lucas i didn't
realize
until i started speaking that perhaps
you want to say something
well you you made the motion so you get
to speak first
president pearson do you have anything
to add uh well you know uh the
the amendment that i withdrew we
discussed and uh
and that later brought us into the
discussion on the the first part of this
so
reading through it it looks like uh
[Music]
to put it in plain english he did what
he said he was gonna do so
i think that that's you know certainly
up for discussion but i'm i'm happy with
it representative lucas do you have a
comment uh i just had a question and and
i uh
i expected the sponsors are the people
moving the amount to speak first so not
a problem at all
um is this basically some of the process
uh for java cars if they object to a
rule yes
yes
they can review and discuss and advise
the commission the commissioner in this
case
no problem
but
in order to actually block it they need
to get the full legislative legislature
behind
so yes they sponsor a resolution
and to rescind her okay
um follow-up fellow
yeah i uh
you know i kind of prefer i did prefer
what
the bill was doing and it was doing
originally
but if there is actually a rules problem
and uh they'll go along with this
and
what's i think it's important to
understand that
that the
commissioners
objected to
uh
executive order would be in suspension
while the legislature would be affirming
or not affirming
the
joint resolution if you will
because the commissioner's order until
legislature had decided one way or the
other
i would may say from my
10 years on on jail car
that
discussion
pointing out air
problems and a little uh
and persuasion
generally
convince the agency
or the commissioner to change their
order so that it is not objectionable
and that's generally in cases where
there are serious
disagreements
on that
on the
order again
representative
yeah uh just
it's a statement made saying that uh
the thing would be um
suspender you know implementation would
be suspended into the legislature
legislature voted so that's the case
with this amendment
yes if you look on line
commissioners or
commissioners shall be prevented from
enforcing such emergency order until
final legislative action is taken or 90
days
okay thank you i just have no chance to
look at it
anyone else
in that case the motion on the floor is
by representing grota to adopt amendment
to house bill
and when ready
representative roy yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative
yes representative allegro no
[Music]
representative bailey
no
representative lonzaro
[Music]
yes
representative judy
no
yes
representative grota
representative o'brien
i see him uh yes okay
uh and the chair yes looks like uh 16 to
two
for adoption of the amendment all right
the amendment has been adopted
representative uh
who has a motion
i have a motion ought to pass with
amendment house bill one with amendment
on house bill 187 and i
that's certainly
no i think we've already discussed it
all right purpose of pearson yeah okay
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on
house bill 187 with them
all right seeing none
there's no further discussion
behold the rule promotion is not to pass
with amendment
zero nine five two
representative roy yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
somebody else is speaking can everybody
mute themselves exactly
thank you
could representatives by group
i will let me repeat where we are
because of this
roy has voted yes
the clerk has voted yes pearson has
voted yes yahoo just voted yes lexus
voted yes
alegro has voted no
bailey has voted yes we are now asking
lonzara
yes
it says a in may but we'll say yes and
no santa
representative
yes yes
represents
yes
representative
representative schmidt
yes
representative schultz yes
representative fellows
yes
representative
frank no
yes
we
representative o'brien
[Music]
he chuckles every time you do it so
maybe you're right yeah maybe you're off
just a little it's fun i'm trying to say
don't ask me yes
volunteers knowledge all right
no so does anyone object to consent
i
madam chair i thank the clerk for
reiterating those votes
we are fortunate to have such a
conscientious clerk
i thank rep
assistant smarling for her excellent
work on dodging back and forth among
amendments
all right
so
we do not yet have the amendment on
house bill 417 it's we will definitely
have it on wednesday
we also have a non-jermaine amendment
to house bill 141 which we're hearing on
wednesday
we will need to vote on both of those
of that day
we also are hearing a number of minor
senate bills
if we can
vote on any of them it's a plus
if we can't
it's that time
so
i hope you will all be here on wednesday
to uh
[Music]
to finish our house bills so
presumably it's a question uh madam
chair
uh 141 and 417 is that is that the
remaining work we have that's the
remaining house bills
as far as my records are are set
up i will be checking with the
with our
committee assistant to make sure i
haven't
dropped one somewhere else
in chair yes
yes just to
am i correct in assuming that uh
even though we will be executing some
senate bills that they would not be on
the calendar in our three
session days in april is that
likely
my thought is that if they are on
consent they might very well go on the
calendar if they are not on consent
they will probably not
thank you for that insight
it's not my choice
even if they decided to i mean on the
senate bill part but just don't get to
it yeah and even if they were on the
calendar
they would be
they they could be easily special
ordered to the end
and if we don't get to them there's no
deadline
okay thank you all and uh
this meaning is